there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey it's us it's friday night you guys
yep it's zach's birthday today
[Laughter]
well we saw it was really funny because
zach just came
into the chat and said yes he's got two
balls in his birthday today and i was
like that's really funny because
literally a minute ago we were talking
about how it was your birthday yeah i
saw it on because i saw it on facebook
when i was like i said i'm gonna have to
get it i'm gonna have to get i said i
would have to get zach a [ __ ]
getting my name gay [ __ ]
i just had like a really funny of
somebody walking into like a fast food
joint
yeah i'd like one of those gay blow
drops yeah
not a straight
that's one of the options would you like
to supersize it yeah
[Laughter]
dance elsewhere yeah
oh my goodness i like that hasberg
action
i'll make that happen
around a dome around the dome
i can see it i can see a whole menu yeah
we'll see i don't know trying to order
it up and [ __ ] yeah i don't know why
this just reminded me of
um of this you'll see where i'm going
with this in a second
the uh the path that i do my hikes on
like right outside of the seminole
kind of trail here every now and then
like it's all shaded with trees right so
all of these dead leaves fall on it so
every now and then they have like a
truck come through there and like
you know do like a leaf blur and blow
the leaves off so people like slip and
fall on them and stuff
and i just started calling it the blow
truck and
because that's what it is it's a truck
with like a big huge leaf blower on the
back
so i called the blowtruck and tom told
me the other day that every time i said
that
he thought of like a food truck except
that it dispensed [ __ ] yeah yeah but
hookers
jump it out jump it up hey
so that's what the [ __ ] menu would be
it would be on the blowtruck
just on the side they would set up you
know on some corner somewhere out in
front of a construction site or wherever
yeah and then you could go up there and
order whatever you wanted
a couple years back i was outside the
starbucks
and starbucks is on this intersection
and at one of the intersections behind
kobe's steakhouse there's this big
empty lot it looks like the woods out
there they had a homeless camp out there
and it had the the county people were
going down there you know
[ __ ] giving them shots and they all
had damn masks on and gloves this is a
years back anyway they had some girl
working out of there out of the damn
homeless camp and her whole thing was
just to walk around
in homemade cut-offs with a [ __ ]
burger king bag just to waving and
saying hey to everybody
that was her way that way the cops you
know she had plausible deniability well
that was pretty smart thing to do like
walking around the bird she's like what
i'm just going to get my lunch like
busting my child she wouldn't come on
starbucks property she got busted on
starbucks properly
so she'd walk around and go hey you get
waving
hey that's where i got the hay [ __ ] in
the [ __ ]
burger king burger king and going hey
waving at everybody yeah seeing what
would happen
trying to get you to follow her hey man
it's like you know girl's gotta do it
girl's gonna do it
down there and the [ __ ] homeless cat
well you know
yeah that the helmets camp's gone now
yeah
they cleared them out well yeah i think
that uh that property is for sale i
think too so
zack says and it's actually a sperm
harvesting operation yes probably
the blower but it works in reverse yeah
i don't know i just picture you said
blow truck i just imagine like those
fast
food trucks pulling up and like 20 of
them girls [ __ ] piling out
hey bags and [ __ ] well i just thought of
blow truck because it's like a tow truck
but with a blower on the back yeah so
that's what i thought of
i mean you know it just goes through the
trail you're not all allowed
to like drive cars on the trail
obviously it's paved but you can't drive
on it but thank you
because they go through there and blow
all the leaves off which i really
appreciate
zach's in there [ __ ] bragging about
his skills
says the bisexual man always telling me
i get the best of little jobs
[Laughter]
he's got bad skills you got yeah you
gotta be good as well
see anybody's out there man just gonna
hit hit up zach he's he's ready he's
ready to go it's his bro
oh my god this went downhill quickly
didn't it
[Laughter]
it's just fresh coming off a diet too
yeah yeah i've been on one off and now
that's what's going on
what's going on got the soaps in there
got tammy's in there taylor's in there
tila still didn't see
the red sun well you know people can't
just watch things at the drop of a hat
you know she's trying to go get a drink
though
uh oh hi pookie don't you do it don't
you do it don't jump up here
she she looked and was like oh she did
that earlier and just stomped all over
the [ __ ]
so hopefully i mean i guess everybody
can hear us nobody's complaining that we
sound like we're under water in a box or
something so
yeah okay um we're not going to have the
laser going because
we suspect that maybe it was a laser
causing us to lose our stream
because that sucks up a lot of data
that's kind of what i was thinking well
because we forgot to turn it on on
wednesday and we didn't lose the stream
on wednesday and then i was like huh i
wonder if it's because
there was so much activity going on in
the background of the thing that it was
like sucking up too much [ __ ]
bandwidth
so we're gonna leave it off and see what
happens you know what i mean
if it's not affecting it then i'll turn
it back on at some point but it's kind
of like
it may be affected it may be that so i
told tom i was like just let's try not
to like flail around we'll just try to
be very still
yeah and not like wave around too much
and maybe it'll be okay
we're just trying to we're trying to
like keep this [ __ ] stream from
crashing
but yeah uh yeah i don't know i don't
know how long this is going to go on
tonight we'll find out
well because it's looking at me like do
you get rip on you getting ready to jump
up on something aren't you
she's like yeah i have that i'm about to
jump up
i'm going to jump up on your devices and
on your drink she's watching it's so
tempting it's so tempting well she last
night we
saw her she was in the backyard sitting
by the tree her little tree in the
backyard
with her little buddy she has a little
buddy i don't know whose cat it is maybe
the
neighbor across the street i'm not sure
but the little cat looks almost exactly
like her almost the same size the same
color
everything except has a tail you know
obviously cookies
yeah they're just like sitting as
they're looking at each other a little
bit little buddies like hanging out just
by the tree
it's so funny i just so i was like oh we
found little twinsies that's so cute
she's just gonna sit there and stare so
i i got her like four big things of
treats today so she's
and and one of them had busted open in
the package so it's like there's little
treats like scattered all over the
carpet so she's doing a little treasure
hunt
like trying to find him i came up with
gonna make a new uh shirt design
it's gonna be a citrus of mercy rip-off
gonna happen the circle says
sisters of mercy and it's gonna the star
with the head
the outline of the head someone put
pookie's head in there it's gonna call
the pookie the mercy
of mercy i feel like it should probably
be pookie's
whole body because one of her most
distinctive features is her little
is her little tail i don't know i wanted
to match that head but yeah
well we could just look at them yeah we
could just put poke that in there yeah
with her little
with the ears with their little ears
yeah that go like that
yeah got a super chat oh we did oh it's
like oh yeah i'm a couple so i'm a
couple seconds behind you oh thank you
amanda
extra shout out to you guys in addition
to my monthly patreon just because daisy
my dog and i
just signed a formal offer letter for a
new job that ended up offering way more
than they initially said that's
awesome yeah that's awesome
congratulations thank you very very much
that's like super cool when that happens
maybe that cat is a supernatural cat and
it's the cat pookie is talking to in the
mirror
maybe it is maybe it is because pookie
does talk to the cat in the mirror
do we have any uh shout outs or anything
like that we actually have two new
patrons this week
okay isn't that exciting yeah uh we have
a
patron named rebecca i call her rebecca
m because we actually have
three she's the third rebecca so lots of
rebecca okay
so thank you very much rebecca also we
have one named
erazo i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
that was just from a couple days ago so
we we got new
patrons that's good we always like
welcome aboard people
welcome aboard yeah we're uh you know
get early access to stuff you get to
vote on stuff you get to vote on movies
and topics and all kind of fun [ __ ]
when i start doing uh my new movie
reviews i'm going to start doing two a
week i've already got like four of them
in the can
and i'll give you early access to those
as well like i said i'll probably post
them on
thursday and saturday for public but so
patrons should be able to see them on
wednesdays and fridays
we have to make a new shipment of shirts
and send them out soon i know we really
need to and
uh we ought to come up with a new design
that we don't have to fuss around
asking people what shirt they want we'll
just send them a [ __ ] it'll just be one
yeah one shirt it is much easier
much easier that way and uh we may have
people's size on record huh and their
addresses and everything on the record
most people i do unless they're fairly
new okay we need to make sure we have
all that stuff yeah well i think
mass mailing whether they contact us or
not
because a lot of y'all [ __ ] don't
answer
do you want to what size and then you
all never answer so you don't get your
shirt
so i want to resolve that so you're
going to get your shirt whether the
answer or not thank you dan
thank you yeah i mean like i said um
you know i do have a list of everybody
that contacted me the last
time or the last couple times and i
wrote down everything like size and
everything
i always check again just in case
because sometimes people have said oh
they wanted a different size because
they were giving it to somebody else or
whatever
um so i always like to check and rather
than just sending them out but
i usually do like a mass email we need
to get their sizes straight and their
address is straight
yeah that would just have a straight
mailing list you get it you get it
yeah like i said i have that but um
we'll see if it's been
updated okay because we have we have had
some new people so we have to like get
all the maybe next
people stuff yeah in april that's
definitely something we should shoot for
i do want to make that pookie shirt but
we have to make another 13 o'clock one
too we have to think of something cool
yeah i mean you know i really like the
last one that i made and i really like
that friday the 13th one that i made so
it's like getting harder to come up with
new [ __ ]
jay made it back how you doing jay all
right
yeah all right so uh the case we're
gonna be talking about tonight i've been
wanting to do this one for a long time i
actually wrote about this one in
uh my first volume of faceless villain
this is a weird ass case
a couple of other channels have covered
it i think buzzfeed unsolved did it
and uh you know a couple of other ones
the weird thing about this case is that
no one's entirely sure if
the kids that are missing are
dead or alive or what it's you know what
i mean it's just like a really really
strange case
there's like time i'm hearing about this
case i haven't done anything any
research or anything i just found out
about danae i've been
been sleeping all day today what a rough
life you have
him and pookie it's like all they do is
just lay in there on the bed and sleep
wasn't feeling that good oh well you
know
it's kind of you know my medication his
medication
medication yeah paper medication yeah i
took that damn estrogen blocker
it should make me sleepy i wonder what's
going on so it's an estrogen blocker and
it makes you
make sleepy yeah i mean i'm sleepy all
the time but that's just because i
don't sleep very well and i wake up
early every [ __ ] day
[ __ ] it [ __ ] up with my [ __ ]
delicate male hormonal balance it hit
you were so delicate
i don't understand it
some dudes say don't [ __ ] with that that
they give those to you but don't [ __ ]
with them i don't think i'm gonna [ __ ]
with them every time i've taken that
[ __ ] after the fella
just feel sleepy as [ __ ] afterwards
we've only you've taken three of them
yeah
taking a total of three of them yeah i
don't think i'm gonna take anymore
well just i mean stop taking them for a
while and just see what happens
like if you're still tired then you know
that it's not fast couple times i took
them
you know they say take them on the day
you take your injection you know what i
mean and every time i
took them with the injection fell
[ __ ] sleepy yeah but i didn't take it
it felt great
interesting
michael shafer says tom is fragile all
dudes are fragile
they are very fragile i think that's why
they make fun of women for being fragile
because they're it's like
no it's a it's a projection thing yeah
tila said wait a minute i
uh i thought those shots were supposed
to boost energy yeah well that the shot
does but he's also
there's a pill there's also a couple of
pills that you have to take along with
that it's like a whole system
it's the whole system it's one thing
counteracting another
see but they're telling me don't
counteract that [ __ ]
see here's the problem if you start
[ __ ] banging up [ __ ] testosterone
testosterone look at aromatizes into
estrogen
if it's a if it's a lot of [ __ ]
testosterone you're gonna have a lot of
estrogen left over
which could cause cause gynecomastia
[ __ ] tits yeah and the first symptom
kind of like i represent that
like sensitive nipples and [ __ ]
so my nipples yeah yeah so they so what
they do is on a daily injection they
want you to take this
estrogen blocker so as it [ __ ]
aromatizes you're not getting you're not
getting the estrogen
but the problem is is that estrogen
[ __ ] does a lot of good [ __ ]
like [ __ ] it controls sex drive it
does all kinds it makes you
it's part of that energy feeling that
you get
so anything that's kind of like it most
dudes
and i'm not taking that much you know i
wasn't prescribed a lot of it um you
know
200 milligrams some guys are taking a
pro bodybuilder weighs 300 pounds
it's on 700 okay so he's
that's like the rock rocks probably take
about 700. um
he's more likely to need those pills
then i would you know what i mean yeah
it's not it's not that much
test so they gave me the weakest one you
know it's like a half
milligram i think i'm i think i'm gonna
stop taking them some guys say don't
take that [ __ ]
just don't control estrogen let it run
wild
yeah estrogen running
[Laughter]
because because the balance of estrogen
to testosterone in other words
proportions of it
are natural for the amount of
testosterone that you have yeah that's
why if you were naturally producing that
testosterone that's would be the natural
amount
of estrogen you would have anyway yeah
so it's not like you're
you're not doing a supernatural dose of
testosterone
you understand what i'm saying yeah what
do they call that chips
super super physiological it's not a
super physiological dose of testosterone
it's just what you were making when you
were a teenager
yeah it's not you're not like you're not
transforming into a woman
or you're getting into you like or the
thing
or something yeah or something like that
yeah you're not doing anything unusual
right so i think i'm gonna stop digging
at you
yeah and now everybody's coming up with
like stuff you might need like a man's
ear
manzier and man ponds yeah
get my nipples pierced oh
i like that idea you would never do that
where's the pity they get ripped out
that's see that's what i always worry
about maybe effect ripped out i'm even
kind of nervous i wear earrings
sometimes i do have pierced ears i
pierced it myself a long time ago
but um even now like when i go out i'm
real reluctant
like to wear them just in case because
like what if you know people get drunk
and we're dancing and they go
like i don't know i just have like
really terrible uh
imaginings like that i think that'd be
like really nasty if that happened
they're talking about phil what are you
doing what's up
what's the matter pokey what are you
doing
she doesn't know where she doesn't know
she's super bored so uh
what else do you have anything else
you've got to talk about about your
hormones
you're talking about hormones too now
jay i'm gonna talk about
yeah women got these little monthly
cycles they got these monthly cycles
men don't have no men don't have that no
no no thank you for
this it's the lifetime arc yeah well we
have that too but then we have that
other [ __ ] and the difference
but it's not fun in case you woman's
like a corkscrew
yeah just a never ending man it sucked
look at oh my goodness pookie is over
there laying on her back with her little
paws sticking up in there again what'd
you say where were you gonna think
you seemed like you were gonna save them
and then you kind of like went over
there no i was just looking at me
i'm just i was just laughing at pookie
because she went over there and
laying on her back and then she's like
looking at the window like what the
[ __ ] going on over there
just gotta get enough alcohol in my
system to wake me up yeah you need to
wake up
yeah wake up [ __ ] hot in here it is
weirdly and you know what's really
strange is that it's not hot outside of
[ __ ] yeah she's so weird so i wish you
guys could see this it's like it's
hilarious like the [ __ ] position
she's like you got her back running
through space yeah she was like and then
she looked at me thank you zach
thank you for giving me that mental
image of tom on those heart-shaped
stripper pasties with the tassels
let me see what the temperature is oh my
god
yeah it's weird because normally it's uh
actually kind of cold in this office i
usually have a little sweater a little
jacket or something
yeah i'm one of those people but it's
weird because normally i'm one of those
people i'm not like one of those girls
because you know how like dudes are
like women are always cold and [ __ ] like
that i'm not usually
usually i'm like too warm you know i'm
just like oh my god i'm dying
and it's like even when it's really cold
outside i'm like please please do not
turn the heat on it has to be really
really freezing cold before i will
consent to having the heat on in the
house or the car or anything because i
can't stand it
but it's not hot in here yeah but
sometimes
sometimes it gets like so cold in this
office for whatever reason
that i need a jacket which is really
weird
and it's really funny because i go in
the bedroom to get the jacket and he's
always like are you cold and i'm like no
i'm just putting on the jacket on for no
[ __ ] reason
of course i'm cold it's not cold in here
he always says
i'm like okay uh i it's cold in here
that's why i'm putting the [ __ ] on
having hot flashes yeah maybe you are it
could be yeah
it could be burning up and burning at
night
those sucked i went through that but it
wasn't as bad as i was expecting but
until it still kind of sucked
it's a what is it outside right now
what's the 72 73
yeah it was it's not actually that it's
not that hot but it's
not cool either like i went out this
morning for my hike and it was
real cloudy and i think it was in the
60s maybe just sit here man this is
gonna
poke what are you doing we're going to
get rid of her she's gonna have to go
outside she'll be all right she'll get
bored in a minute
what's she doing she i just bought her a
bunch of box of treats and so she might
be like
trying to dig through the damn books oh
that's all right
okay bryce j says tom is my role model
yeah we need to unpack that situation
amanda says i avoid hangovers with
pedialyte a lot of people have said
about that i've never done it but
i don't get hangovers anymore because i
usually take um i usually take
a bunch of aspirin before i go to sleep
and uh
that usually works out so i've had a
hangover since i started doing that
all right so you want to talk about this
case now or are you going to be like
eating into it they're talking about
justice league in there
yeah that four hour one
is it really four hours yeah it's just
been pretty good yeah i've heard it was
pretty good
snyder cut and dude oh my god four hours
yeah do they have like intermission in
the middle so i can like go to the
bathroom and whatnot like you don't need
that anymore because you can just pause
the [ __ ] yeah
not like back in the old days what it's
like yeah that's good
that's gonna be the future anyway the
movies are just gonna be four or five
hours long it's gonna be like a mini
series because i don't think they're
going to be opening up amc and [ __ ]
regal theaters is gone yeah it's like
it seems like amc has gone like a few of
the theaters are still open but they've
just gone pretty much to an online
streaming
service because i still get emails from
them and they're just like hey this
movie's out this movie now but they're
just doing the [ __ ] simultaneously
theater attendance was bad anyway for
the past five ten years
it was just slowly trailing off people
didn't give a [ __ ] about that other than
like a few big movies every now and then
that everybody would go see but not
economically viable anymore
i mean yeah it kind of sucks because
like i said i really like going to the
movies but
they are kind of a lot to maintain like
i said i don't i don't really have a
problem with them going more in an indie
direction where they're kind of smaller
and you know you have something like the
enzian here in orlando where
it's like a cafe they serve food and
beer and [ __ ] like that and they show
indie movies documentaries like you know
weird [ __ ]
i like that funny thing is is that movie
theaters predate television
that was that was that's what people
used to do every day
before television was embedded all right
um
so it it's it's a it's a very old
business model it's it's a dinosaur and
then it ended up being kind of like an
experience and we were growing up in the
80s and in the 90s they had really good
movies at that time
especially you know compared to
everything else that was going on so
you'd go and you see terminator 1 and
you'd see predator 1 and you'd see
terminator termination it was
quite an event you know yeah it had
there was an experience to go into it
but that's kind of gone now that last
couple years that we were going to the
theater i didn't really
very rarely maybe like one movie out of
30
would i get an experience like that and
it'd be like seeing the john wick movies
yeah i mean some movies absolutely need
to be seen on a big screen like just
to appreciate them but and then there's
a whole
generations of people who are younger
than us that did not grow up
with the experiences that we had in
other words
they didn't grow up in the 80s seeing
cool movies in the theater
they just didn't they ever they see
everything off a [ __ ] handheld device
which like i said some some movies some
genres it doesn't really matter but i do
kind of feel like
you at least need to see [ __ ] on a big
screen tv so some genres obviously some
[ __ ] doesn't matter but a person in
their 20s can't relate to that
a lot yeah i talked to them they're just
like huh what what why would i want to
do that
they got headphones on and they had it
have it in front of their hands
and if you actually look at the screen
you
hold it up it's kind of like having a
tablet yeah that's true you know i mean
it's not it's not a big difference
so they didn't grow up with the with
that movie experience that we did so
they're just they don't have an
emotional connection to it so they just
don't go
oh they'll well yeah and like i said
you know in in a lot of ways streaming
is kind of better because like i said
you can pause it you can
it can be in your own house you don't
have to listen to a bunch of [ __ ] ass
clowns like talking
you can have whatever snack you want and
they're free the one that really drove
me [ __ ]
crazy is where i'm in a damn we were in
the [ __ ]
the what was it the dolby theater the
expensive one
yeah with the reclining seats like all
that it's damn near empty
theater all right and watching these
movies and some big old [ __ ] white
dude in his shorts comes in
and sits down right next to me and takes
his [ __ ] shoes and socks off
and i got these [ __ ] big ass [ __ ]
stinky [ __ ] smelly
feet this [ __ ] what like what the
[ __ ] are people
thinking he just takes his shoes off and
i'm just going with these [ __ ] stinky
ass
see this is okay now this is the person
that always sits near me on the airplane
is the person that takes their shoes and
socks off and leans their feet like yeah
yeah you clean it up and they're
like really man really yeah
yeah they are old enough to know better
the ironic thing is if you did it to
them they would probably like have a
[ __ ] freak out
and he's just like a very you know
overweight
over the hill middle-aged dude
who thinks he's in his [ __ ] den
yeah it's like too bad he didn't stay
there yeah i mean i will never
understand people like i can understand
if the movie theater is crowded okay and
there's nowhere to sit and you have to
sit by another person
if the movie theater is half [ __ ]
empty don't
sit right god damn next to me or write
goddamn in front of me
there's tons of empty seats why just why
would you do that
like i hate the way i try to get as far
away from other people as possible
you know what i mean if i sit way the
[ __ ] out on the aisle to stay away from
people then i will do that
i don't understand why people got to
like get right up on you like that
just [ __ ] off [ __ ] geez tina's going
yeah
yeah t he was nasty it's pretty nasty he
had them [ __ ] bermuda shorts and then
[ __ ]
[ __ ] hawaiian shirt type thing with
the [ __ ]
sometimes i wonder if that's like some
kind of like reality show
yeah you know how they used to have
candid camera back in the 70s and like
they would have some because it's like
can anybody be that [ __ ] clueless i
guess they can look like he had a damn
turtle underneath his shirt just [ __ ]
big old belly and pale as [ __ ] i'm just
pale
dude look i can never nev we're in
florida if you're real [ __ ] pale here
you got you well you live in your mom's
basement
or you're not from here you're not from
here so i just
i mean because you get radiation just
walking outside just
opening your window you don't even have
to go outside if it's all comes in
through your window and like basically
i'm very pale for
a florida person and i'm not even that
pale um tila said
same thing happened to me he took off
his shoes and put them up while eating
sunflower seeds cracking the sunflowers
yeah do they do it on purpose well
i mean i there was like an industry
analysis and
one of the things that they said was is
that that was one of the problems that
they had
with theater attendance is that is that
in the modern era
the guests couldn't stand each other
they don't like each other well yeah
because people got so
imposed on each other well it is a space
bubble people have a much bigger space
bubble now well i don't blame them i
have i've always had a really big space
bubble ever since the 70s man get the
[ __ ] away from yeah and people are just
rude
and they call all kind of mouth noises
sucking on their teeth and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] they just
people are gross man and then it's like
and and some
some of the bad experiences i've had too
were like old people that didn't know to
turn their phone off
um you know just [ __ ] like that it's
just like really
it seems like really obvious common
sense [ __ ] but i guess some people just
think and then if you yell at them
they'll just be like
what i'm just i paid for ticket to you
they get all [ __ ] indignant about it
what did he say oh my god i can't
understand
that that was from the 1990s i still
remember that vividly
did i tell that story what's happening
what's he doing
who's this now he ate the goat
yeah he was right behind me and his wife
was just like oh my god they were like
[ __ ] 100 years old
and he clearly had no [ __ ] idea what
was going on although you do that
sometimes too like you're just who's
this now
[ __ ] what's going on you do you've
done it before and i'm just like shh
i'll tell you later
even when you do it at home i'm just
like i don't know i'm trying to watch
the movie well that's cause i'll leave
how did it come back
is she gonna die what happened yeah it's
it's
it's terrible so yeah i like i said i
don't mind going to a movie but honestly
when i walk in there and there's nobody
else in there but us it's like i'm just
like
yes like the whole [ __ ] thing to
myself one
you know i don't like watching movies
with other people but i do like going to
the movie theater like i like that
experience i just don't like other
people that you know generally
um all right so are we ready to talk
about this okay
some of the people that complain about
are like jesus christ you've been on for
like 35 minutes what the [ __ ]
uh yes we've been going on for half an
hour about [ __ ] but you know that's
that's
everybody's going to be here is here
already some of them left yeah
probably because they're like i thought
you guys were gonna stop [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] but you know
at least on this one um i'm pretty
familiar with this case and
uh you know at least we're just talking
about one case so we can talk about like
theories and uh all this other kind of
stuff too when we
get through all the oh is she biting
your hand yes good
uh so you know when we get down to all
the details and whatnot
so let's go back to 1945.
it was christmas eve fayetteville
west virginia there's a family called
the sodder family george and jenny
sotter
and their 10 children although one of
their kids their oldest son was away in
the army
but their nine younger ones were still
at home
um pretty uh you know middle class upper
middle class family uh
george sodder was actually an italian
immigrant i believe his wife was as well
uh but they had done um he had done
pretty well for himself like uh you know
eventually like got into the business
i'll get into that later on
but so they have this house it was
christmas eve
and i guess uh this particular christmas
eve kind of a normal christmasy for them
they had all their you know
the tree up and all the lights and
everything all the kids were still up
i think they had let them um open some
of their presents early
so some of the younger kids kind of
wanted to stay up late so they could
play with their stuff and you know enjoy
the tree more and all this other kind of
stuff so the parents said that it was
uh okay so five
of their children as i said they had ten
but uh nine were still at home
so five of the children maurice who was
fourteen
martha who was twelve lewis who was ten
jenny who was eight and betty who was
six um
said that they would wanted to stay up
later and play with some of their toys
so their mom whose name was also jenny
um
said yeah okay that's fine we're all
going to bed though um
just before you go to bed make sure that
you do like all your chores before you
go to bed
so their chores before they went to bed
they had some farm animals so
they said to the kids you know go out
and make sure the farm animals are
fed and like you know they're all locked
up for the night and everything like
that
turn off all the christmas lights you
know lock the doors close the curtains
do all the regular like going to bed
[ __ ]
so then george and jenny and their four
other kids
went upstairs to bed their eldest
daughter
fell asleep on the couch now
a few hours later uh very early on the
morning of
christmas day the 25th 1945
the phone rings in the middle of the
night i believe it was something like 12
30 1 o'clock in the morning
so jenny the mom she gets up and
uh she goes into the hall and answers it
now there's a woman on the other end of
the line
um and she said it kind of sounded like
someone was calling from a party or
something like that
because she said she heard a bunch of
voices in the background and there was
like something that sounded like glasses
clinking or something
and so this woman asks her for a person
that jenny didn't know who it was
so jenny's like well i think you have
the wrong number
so then the woman kind of laughed really
weirdly and then she hangs up
now jenny was like huh that was pretty
weird okay
um but then she notices like while she's
on the phone she looks out of the living
room and she sees those damn kids
allegedly have uh left all the lights on
um you know that she finds out that the
door is unlocked all this other kind of
stuff she doesn't see any of the kids in
the room where they were but she's like
man they just they didn't do anything i
told them to do so she gets like really
annoyed
and she goes in there and locks the door
you know closes the drapes
turns all the lights off and everything
is just like man this [ __ ] kid you
can't tell them to do anything right
so she just figured oh they forgot about
it so she closed up the house and goes
back to bed
now she's only back in bed for about
half an hour
and then she hears um a noise
she said later that it sounded like
something kind of heavy like a stone or
something
hitting the roof of the house and then
rolling down
the slope of the roof um she said this
was about 1 30 in the morning
now shortly after she heard this strange
noise
she starts smelling smoke in the house
so she shakes george awake her husband
and runs out of the bedroom now
at this stage the hallway of the house
is filled with smoke
and the stairway uh going up to i think
they were on their bedroom was on the
first floor but the kids that had stayed
up late like the five kids they had two
bedrooms that were up on the second
floor or the third floor i can't
i don't remember i think it was the
second floor um so they were on
the second floor so there was like a
floor above so she comes out in the hall
and she sees like a bunch of smoke and
some flames and the staircase is already
essentially on fire so they can't get up
to
the kids right so
they basically like shot up their stairs
like you know we everybody has to get
out just you know get the [ __ ] out of
the house
so sadly as i said they couldn't get up
the stairs
they didn't know where the five kids
that stayed up late were
um because they didn't see them in the
living room but they didn't know if
they'd gone upstairs because like i said
they'd all said they were in
they'd been downstairs you know and now
they were missing
so they ran out of the house and then
realized that the five kids were not out
there
and so they started freaking out because
they assumed
that they had gone up to bed and then
you know and so
the since the staircase was on fire they
couldn't get to them like from the
inside of the house
so george um as he would you know he's
like trying to save his five kids
so he says well we we're gonna have to
get into the house from the outside
so he busts a window um cut his arm open
it was bleeding everywhere
but he couldn't really um see anything
like the the house was pretty much very
quickly being uh consumed by fire
um i think i read somewhere that it had
started in the office but i'm not
entirely sure if that's the case but the
the house was made of wood which that's
never good uh so the fire spread like
really really quickly
now he knew that like some of the kids
made it out
um his two-year-old sylvia uh they got
her out because she was in the same
room as them um 17-year-old marion who
was the oldest
daughter uh she was outside and they had
two sons
john who was 23 and george jr who was 16
they all made it out um they had been in
the upstairs bedroom but they were able
to get out before the fire got too bad
um so the other five maurice martha
lewis and jenny
and betty um were probably still in the
house at this stage
so what he decided to do he's like okay
well i'm gonna have to climb up
to the second floor window now
weirdly and this is one of the things
that makes this mysterious among
many other strange things about this
case
was that normally he kept a ladder
propped up against the side of the house
right so he goes around the side of the
house to get it and he's going to climb
up to the second floor window bedroom
window and get them all out
the ladder is not there which is very
strange
um so he starts flipping out so the
ladder's not there he can't find it you
know it's dark outside it's freezing
cold
it's you know it's christmas eve in west
virginia so he's running around
he can't find the ladder so he decides
okay well
he ran um like a trucking business he
had started out hauling dirt and then he
did
um you know coal and various other kinds
of freight so he had two coal trucks
and they i i think they were like bucket
trucks so they kind of had you know they
had like a riser thing on them so he had
a couple of those like out in a garage
or a shed or whatever so he's like okay
well i'm just gonna get one of those
trucks pull it under the window and then
i'm gonna climb on top of it and then i
can bust the window and get them out
so he goes in there and he tries both
trucks
neither of them will start even though
they had been working the day before
which again very unusual
so at this point he's like well maybe we
can try to put the fire out
so they had like this big rain barrel
that was outside the house
he tries to scoop water out of it to put
the fire out but
it was frozen solid um
so basically it's he's like just losing
his mind at this point so
um they didn't obviously their house was
on fire they were outside
this was 1945 nobody had cell phones
obviously
so his daughter marion who was 17 she
runs to a neighbor's house
to call the fayetteville fire department
however when they called the fire
department they well they couldn't get
an operator to pick up
right which seems a little weird i mean
it was christmas eve it was a holiday
so it's kind of a small town maybe
everybody just took the [ __ ] night
off or whatever like they thought
hey no crimes will happen so you know
but they couldn't get an operator to
pick up so
um basically so another neighbor saw the
house was on fire
and went to a bar nearby and
tried to call from there but again they
couldn't get an operator
on the line so at this point the
neighbor was like man [ __ ] this
so the neighbor gets in his car and
drives to
into town and he finds the fire chief
whose name was fj morris and
at this point this town did not have
anything like a modern uh you know fire
alarm type of system or anything like
that
basically they were just like well you
had to do like a phone tree
like one person would call like hey
we'll call this firefighter and that
firefighter has to call another
firefighter
like to get everybody out there to fight
the [ __ ] fire which is their job but
you know
it's a long time ago uh it was yeah now
sadly so the fire department
was only two and a half miles away from
the solder home
but it took them until eight in the
morning
on christmas morning to get there eight
in the morning
now i think what happened too was that
when they first
found the fire chief fj morris
they were just like just man go get the
fire truck and bring it the [ __ ]
house is burning down and there's five
kids inside like trapped inside there
fj morris supposedly said i don't know
how to drive the fire truck
we have to wait until somebody who knows
how to drive the fire truck
comes on shift that's
allegedly what he told them so a fire
chief who can't drive a fire truck so
i'm like okay
so yeah um by the time they arrived
uh you know something like seven hours
after the [ __ ] fire had started
obviously there was nothing left of this
house but a pile of ash
there was just pretty much nothing there
um you know a couple
a few appliances and like some [ __ ]
burned
planks and whatnot that's all that was
left everything was gone
now at this stage as you would
george and jenny sonner soder assumed
that the five children had been trapped
in the house and had burned to death
inside the ruins
however um the fire chief and the
you know investigators and all that they
turned up on christmas day
and went through the remains
of the house however they found
no bodies um
you know it and the thing about it is
that at first
uh the fire chief was like well maybe
the blaze was hot enough to completely
cremate them
which unlikely unlikely
um and because i mean this
the thing about it is that this is one
of the things that kind of made
the solder suspicious um was the fact
that they found
zero evidence and not even a bone shard
or anything
even though yeah even though there were
some like like i said appliances and
things like that they found [ __ ] like
that in there
um but if you talk to
you know people who uh you know work at
crematoriums
for example which is exactly the same
thing it's like burning a body to death
uh burning a body to death burning a
dead body
burning a dead body you know what i
meant um you know basically you have to
i know this is like morbid but you have
to cook that body at what like 2000
degrees or something like that for a
long time for and
you have to do it for a long time for a
couple of hours and even then you still
have bone fragments left that you have
to crush
yeah i mean when you get the cremains it
doesn't burn down like that they have
mush doesn't really burn right so the
fact that
no remains at all were found in the
ruins of this house
um you know started to make the parents
suspicious
so um so another thing too
so there's like several mysteries going
on with this so
let's kind of get into this so like i
said chief morris uh basically said oh
well the bodies probably were
cremated because it was really hot or
whatever even though the fire had burned
really quickly i mean the house burned
down in like in less than an hour i
think
so when even if the fire had been hot
enough it didn't burn for
long enough to have completely
obliterated five bodies
impossible eh but extremely unlikely
you know it's just extremely unlikely
so they have a state police inspector
come he goes through the rubble
and um looking for a cause of the fire
now he said oh it was probably just a
faulty wiring which
at first the sodders didn't really have
you know they were obviously they
thought they just lost five of their
children
um they were in horrible you know their
go in horrible morning
you know and shock and trauma and
everything so they didn't really
question it
at first um you know so they were like
okay yeah the kids were completely
burned up
um you know yes it was faulty wiring or
whatever
now sadly because george sodder was
you know had had such a traumatic
experience basically
a day or two after the fire he
bulldozed the whole site over like after
it had been gone through by the
investigators and everything
um because he just wanted to erect a
memorial to like his dead children so he
wasn't real
and like i said at that time he wasn't
really questioning
you know the official statement about
the cause of the fire and what had
happened to the children
um so the coroner's office issued five
death certificates for the kids
um you know just before new year came
already a lot of fishy [ __ ] well yeah oh
wait it gets
fishier where is the
bodies that's what i mean it gets fishy
yeah
okay so uh the cause was attributed to
fire
or suffocation uh meaning the kids had
probably died from smoke inhalation and
then had burned up
so much so that they found as i said not
a single
trace of any of the five bodies anywhere
which
like i said very very unlikely
so let's go back and talk a little bit
about
uh george and jenny sotter's history
because
this might have some bearing on
the cause of the fire and
why uh the kids maybe were not found in
the fire
so george sodder as i mentioned earlier
he was an italian immigrant he was
actually born
giorgio sadhu in sardinia
in 1895. now he ended up immigrating to
the u.s
in 1908 he was 13 years old
him and his brother who was a little bit
older they came to
ellis island and americanized their
names
like a lot of immigrants did
so basically his brother kind of got
there and was like yeah [ __ ] this i
don't like this place and he went back
to italy like almost immediately so
george
13 years old was left in the u.s
alone um so he ended up
actually getting work uh in the
railroads in pennsylvania
um you know just kind of like just
little [ __ ] jobs like you know carrying
water to the people that worked on the
railroads and whatever
um after a few years he ended up moving
to smithers west virginia now
as he got a little bit older he sort of
like worked his way up he was
in a way he was kind of like one of
those like american like immigrant
success stories where he came here with
nothing when he was
13 years old and actually made like a
pretty nice
like middle class life for himself right
um
and like i said he really did start it
with nothing he just started working on
the railroads
when he was a kid and then he um when he
got older and he got his license he
started driving working as a driver
and then eventually was able to put away
enough money to start his own trucking
company
um you know he's just started hauling
dirt for construction
and then he started doing coal and
freight and stuff like that
now uh he ended up meeting his wife
jenny uh who was the daughter of she was
also an
italian immigrant she had come over when
she was very young when she was three
years old with her family
um her family owned a music store
so he had gone into the music store that
day and met her when she was so they got
married later on
so between 1923 and 1943 they had 10
children together like i said
now this particular fayettesville west
virginia
at least at this time in uh you know
around the time that they moved there
it was uh kind of a small town but it
had a really big
italian immigrant community um
so a lot of people in town knew the
sauders like i said because george owned
his own uh hauling company
um and a lot of people said they were
kind of like uh
one person was quoted that knew them was
quoted as saying they were one of the
most respected middle class families
around
they had like a nice house they had like
a bunch of kids um you know kind of well
regarded in the community
now one thing that maybe wasn't so well
regarded and again this is why i bring
this up because there might have been
some like nefarious [ __ ] going on with
this [ __ ]
uh fire was that um
george not he was a nice guy seemed like
but he wasn't shy about telling people
what he really thought
you know um and he had some pretty
strong opinions
about stuff and was not shy about
sharing them
one of the things that he had very
strong opinions on was his hatred of
mussolini now um
a lot of people it's you know it's it's
weird in hindsight but it's you know
this is the 1940s
there were a lot of italian immigrants
in the u.s who were very pro-mussolini
and
kind of saying that you were against
mussolini like some of the other italian
immigrants might not like that so much
so he did get into some verbal
altercations with some other people
in the italian american community about
his dislike of uh
muslim yeah that might that might trip
some people out
how you could be unpopular for not
liking a fascist
which i know like i said that's very
funny like to think about it's funny
only in modern terms
yeah fascism in the 30s 20s 30s
40s was [ __ ] super popular super
popular
it was it was real popular in the united
states
it was not considered a um a derogatory
term to call somebody a fascist
when really all where that word comes
from i think it was the
the romans had a symbol that they used
um i think it was called fashion fashion
or
fashion i think was the name of it in
latin and it was just
a bunch of little sticks together in a
big bundle with a little
axe head on it once one
stick on its own is weak but a whole
bunch of sticks makes a [ __ ] powerful
weapon
that's what it is really all they used
it as a national symbol
it just means union unionist
that's all fascist means union so you
could say you know united states is
fascist
everything's fast anything that requires
unity and teamwork and group
group thinking is fascist at least in
its original definition
yeah the only difference the only
difference between
fascism and other kinds of unionist type
things is that
that fascist political parties
tended to wear uniforms they'd make up a
uniform and wear it
as a political party not part of the
military just imagine if the republicans
and democrats wore uniforms that's what
it would be like
but there was really nothing unusual
about them it was
socialist or maybe they were capitalist
or whatever
it was just a style they just wore a
uniform and they were a unionist
and some of them were technocrats
so i just think it's interesting now
after world war ii
fascism is a bad thing or it's you know
yeah i mean like i said
prior to uh you know prior to that it
you know it was still like
you know there was still some debate to
be had about it and
so you know a lot has been said about
um george's outspoken hatred of
mussolini as maybe a reason why he might
have been targeted by some other italian
americans in the community because
he did you know reportedly get into a
lot of verbal altercations about it
another thing
that's interesting about him too is that
he would never tell anybody why he left
italy even though he left italy like at
a very young age
he was very very cagey about why he
wanted to leave
like if anybody asked him about it he
would just like shut right up
so no one really knew like why he'd
wanted to leave
man it says i was in a teacher's union
it wasn't fascist yes it was
yes it was no it worked
fascists just means group or teamwork or
union that's that's what it meant but
because of world war
ii it has a negative comet connotation
but all the winners were fascist anyway
you know soviet union was fascist the
united states you could consider that
well was that technically fascist i
don't know
it's hard to say it's a union any any
kind of
teamwork that's all the fascist meant
not all fascists were italians not all
fascists were germans
not all there was fascist parties all
over the world
they were like that but you don't hear
about them they didn't really do
anything
you know yeah right but yeah so like i
said a lot of people
brought that up because you got into a
lot of arguments about it
because there were a lot of mussolini
supporters among the italian american
community and others like uh
in the us and particularly in the small
community where they lived like i said
fansville west virginia was
not big um it's in the appalachians yeah
but um
you know there was a large
italian-american community there
so um so
in the days following the tragedy the
fire
while george is bulldozing over
the lot where his house used to be and
where he thinks the body of his children
are and he's thinking about um you know
what he wants as a memorial he's like
planting flowers there and stuff like
that
he starts thinking about some really
weird [ __ ]
that didn't really
it didn't really like catch his
attention at the time
but in light of the fire and the alleged
deaths
uh seems a lot weirder in retrospect
one of these things was that he
remembered
that there was a dude that um
it was probably it was like a month or
two before the fire
and he'd never seen this dude before he
shows up at the house
and he's asking about work he wants a
job
so he turns up and he
kind of goes around to the back of the
house like him and george are talking
he goes around to the back of the house
specifically points to two
fuse boxes and says at least according
to george
this is going to cause a fire someday
which like i said george didn't think
anything about it at the time
but in light of what happened later
seemed a little weird
um george thought it was a little bit
weird at the time because he had just
had the house
rewired or he had just had all of the
wiring checked like by the power company
um so it didn't appear that there was
anything wrong with it at the time so he
just thought it was very strange that
this random dude
who was looking for a job would kind of
go around behind his house and go oh
you know almost sounds a little bit like
that
nice business you got here shame if
something happened to it kind of thing
it's you know what i mean it's like a
little bit threatening
what are you doing back there pookie
she's trying to get in trouble she's
yeah she's like sure she's like what
makes noise
yeah what makes noise leave it alone
she's like oh paper makes noise with my
claws
yeah dj maniac i require chocolate
pudding be right back it's like he got
chocolate pudding the other day that was
really funny something people are
buffering
really yeah oh my god please don't tell
me that yes that's probably just bees no
maybe it's not i mean i think it's okay
bill cosby roofies dj's pudding
i just i'll tell you something right now
nothing to do with bill cosby but i i
used to love those [ __ ] pudding pops
those were so [ __ ] good the chocolate
ones not the vanilla ones were kind of
gross but
you know yeah i just i just remember
that [ __ ] commercial that he was in
with the [ __ ] pudding pops
so terrible in retrospect but um
yeah so so this dude shows up and so
like i said he thought that was a little
strange
now right around the same time period uh
this other guy
shows up at the house like a
door-to-door salesman type of dude
and he was trying to sell george some
life insurance
for his family and george is like you
know no thank you i don't really
require any life insurance at this point
in time
um at which point the guys seem to get
really
um butt hurt like in a really
outsized sort of way like you'd think
that he'd just be like okay well bye but
no
he said and this according to george he
said
your goddamn house is going up in smoke
and your children
are going to be destroyed that's what he
said that this dude said
when he didn't want any life insurance
so you know
a little weird okay uh people are yeah
she's getting bad back there stop it she
wants attention
yeah she was laying down there listening
to you talk to you but she was low on
her to sleep and then she's like i can't
sleep she jumped up
you can sleep pokey you can if you want
to
uh yeah yeah beastness says it's me
i'm uploading and downloading at the
same time we'll see you guys there
you can't do that well you can but you
know it's just gonna buffer
come here pope get hiding
oh there she is there she is i'll put
you outside come on let's go
put her clothes on come here maybe
she'll find her little friend and they
can hang out by the tree
yeah she's like no no i don't want to
now she's being bred she's like i want
to stay in here with you guys and like
make noise
all right so like i said even though
even though these two things in
hindsight seem really strange
if this just happened to you like
[ __ ] randomly like some dude just
came up and said some [ __ ] like that
you'd be like okay whatever dude like
[ __ ] off
but so they didn't really think about at
the time even though they thought it was
weird
now a couple of the older sons
also remembered something uh kind of
weird that had happened as well
they said that right before christmas
they had seen this dude they'd never
seen before and he was
um kind of parked along highway 21
and he was watching the younger kids
when they were coming like i presume
they were walking home from school so he
was like watching them and he just like
remembered it because he thought that
was very strange
now a lot has been made too
of the weird um phone call
that came to the house on the night of
the fire
i'm not really sure if that has anything
to do with anything
it could just be that it was a
coincidence and that it was a wrong
number
but it was interesting that it woke
jenny up
in time to see that all of the
um you know that all the lights were
still on that the door was unlocked and
all that kind of stuff she did see
marion like i said it was 17 she was
still asleep on the couch
but all the other kids like the five
younger kids uh were not there but she
didn't think anything about it because
she thought they'd already gone upstairs
so at this point because they were
remembering all this stuff and then they
were just kind of you know once they had
sort of
cleared their heads a little bit i guess
like after they got through the trauma
of the fire
and them thinking that these five
children were dead they started thinking
how strange it was
that there was no sign of the five
children
in the fire like no bones no nothing um
you know as i said that seems very very
unlikely
so jenny sotter started getting like
really obsessed with it
she would have she would have like
animal bones like chicken bones or like
you know bones from
stuff she was cooking like beef joints
or whatever and she would
um put them in fires to see like what
would happen if it would completely
consume them she would like burn them
for a long time and see
what would happen um and she's like
every single time she did that
obviously all that was left was a bunch
of burned bones she's like she couldn't
she couldn't get the fire hot enough to
burn it long enough like for it to
consume to consume them completely
yeah so she started thinking there's
something
weird here sounds like somebody stole
her children to me
that's well that's kind of what they
started to believe
um so and as i said in the fire they
found no bones but they did find
some household appliances uh in the
basement of the house which were still
they were burned up but they were like
still you could still tell what they
were
yeah um and uh yeah and so like i said
jenny went to a
dude that worked at a crematorium the
local crematorium
and uh asked you know how long does it
take to completely get rid of the bones
like i mentioned before
um it has to be the fire has to be 2000
degrees at least it has to burn for at
least two hours
and even then there are still some bone
fragments left that have to be uh
crushed at the end even with that
and um you know their house had burned
up in less than an hour i believe it was
only 45 minutes before the house was
completely consumed
even if the fire had gotten to 2000
degrees which unlikely
at a house fire of this type um it
wouldn't have been long enough to
completely consume five bodies
completely so that there was no sign of
them left um
you know and so then they remembered
some other weird things that had
happened too
um when they kind of came to
uh kind of check out
the uh the fire like before he bulldozed
everything
over they had like this telephone
repairman guy come
and he said that the telephone lines to
the house
looked like they'd been cut and not
burned through
now if jenny remembered
that she had gotten a phone call at
about 12 30 on
uh christmas morning and the phone was
working then
so at some point somebody must have cut
their phone lines
after that point right so like i said
the more you think about it the more
it's looking like [ __ ] arson
um another thing that's kind of strange
is that even though
the um official report said that the
fire had been caused
by faulty wiring um they did notice
that when the house was burning like a
bunch of the christmas lights were still
on
which you would kind of think that some
of the power would have been blown out
you know what i mean if if faulty wiring
had been the cause of the fire
but some of the lights in the house were
still on like even while the house was
burning uh at least downstairs like all
the lights were still on
um there was also later on
after the uh case kind of hit the media
a witness came forward and said that you
know
i saw a guy uh you know while the house
was burning or shortly before that
and he was stealing a block and tackle
you know the thing that they used to
pull car engines out
he was taking that out he was stealing
it from
the property um so
that kind of leads me to believe that
maybe
he had [ __ ] with george's trucks
because like i said george had tried to
put the trucks like under the window to
pull his kids out
and neither of them would start even
though they had been working the day
before
so somebody was [ __ ] with these
people's [ __ ]
is what i'm saying um
also i think that guy i don't remember
if it was the same guy if it was a
different guy but he actually admitted
yeah i cut the telephone lines i thought
it was electrical lines though but he
didn't really say like why he was
cutting
the power to the house like you know
what i mean it was just like a whole
[ __ ] weird situation
now a couple days later i think it was
you know a few days or a week or
something later the family was back
visiting the site where their house used
to be and sylvia who was a two-year-old
she was kind of digging around in the
dirt like two-year-olds do
and she found this object in the yard it
was like a hard rubber
rubber ball
and when she kind of pulled it out of
the dirt jenny remembered
that not too long after that weird phone
call like before she noticed the fire
starting
she'd heard something hit the roof and
then roll down it
and then she's like is this what this is
because it looked like
it could have been um some type of
incendiary device
you know what i mean that someone was
like throwing at their house
now so at this stage because
of all of these weird little things
about and another thing too is that the
latter you know what i mean
like the latter that he kept like uh
propped up against the side of the house
all the time
they found that later but it was like in
a ditch it was still on the property but
you couldn't really see it like from the
eye line because somebody had like
kind of thrown it down in a ravine or
something so
obviously someone has been on these
people's property
[ __ ] with their [ __ ] they moved the
ladder on purpose they
maybe um you know [ __ ] with a truck so
they wouldn't start
um you know somebody cut their telephone
line so they couldn't call
anyone um so it really does seem like
arson
was you know the cause of the fire not
just a faulty wiring obviously
another thing too is that thank you
louise
long time watcher first time chatter
hope y'all are having a rad day much
love from melbourne australia
thank you very much all the way across i
wonder what time it is over there
time to give money
i guess so yeah
so at this stage george and jenny
have started to become convinced that
their children did not die in the fire
but had been kidnapped prior to the fire
because someone had set the fire and
someone had taken their children
possibly somebody that was
getting revenge on them getting revenge
on george for all the stuff that he had
said
um you know he must have pissed someone
off uh you know that's kind of the going
theory
and so they decided that they were just
gonna
[ __ ] burn his house down and kidnap
five of his kids for whatever reason
now there were some sightings of the
kids later on and now
i'm always kind of i'm always kind of
skeptical of sightings because
i've written about a lot of cases where
um someone disappears and then
there's like all these like a rash of
sightings like hey i saw him in a
denny's somewhere i saw this and that
but then like later it turns out that
they were dead the whole time like
they'll find their body and it was like
it was been there since they disappeared
so obviously that couldn't have been
them
so i'm always like really skeptical
about that but
um just for the sake of completion
i will say that a lot of people said
that they
saw kids that could have been these kids
you know what i'm saying um there was
one woman
who the night of the fire like while it
was still going on
and she actually knew the kids like you
know she was a neighbor or whatever
she said that she saw the five kids or
at least some of them like peeking out
the window of a car that was going by
you know what i mean like while the fire
was going on and like i said she was
she knew the kids so she probably would
have recognized them she said she saw
them
and she didn't know like she didn't
think anything about it at the time
because she didn't know that they were
supposed to be
in the house you know what i'm saying
she just like saw oh i saw him peeking
out this car window that was going by
um there was also another woman and she
worked at like a
kind of a tourist place or a rest stop
or whatever between fayetteville and
charleston
and that was about 50 miles away and she
said the morning after the fire
uh she worked in like the cafe there
and she said that she brought them
breakfast
like that they were sitting at a table
um
with uh a couple of adults like two
women and two men
um but all four of them italian she said
the car that they were driving had
florida license plates
um she said she didn't remember she said
she thought it was the day after the
fire like christmas day or the day after
that she couldn't remember exactly but
she said that she did see them
because like i said their pictures kind
of went out all over the media
um you know and george and jenny also
after they figured out that their kids
might be still alive
they actually bought a billboard
in fayetteville that was up
for like 40 years it might still be
there if anybody's like from west
virginia i'm not really sure i think
it's been taken down subsequently
but it was there for like four decades
with these kids pictures on there
so so yeah so there were sightings there
um but she said this
this whole party like there was four
adults two women two men and these five
children
that looked like the solder kids and she
said they stayed in a big room at the
hotel
with a whole bunch of beds registered
about midnight
she said that she'd tried to talk to the
kids
but the men appeared hostile and
wouldn't let her
talk to them um and then he started like
talking in italian and she didn't know
what they were saying and then after
that she said the whole party stopped
talking to her
and so she thought well okay i guess
they don't want me [ __ ] with them and
she didn't talk to them anymore like i
said at this point
um she didn't know that these kids might
be
kidnapped you know what i'm saying
because that didn't go out until much
later
now 1947 a couple years after the fire
george and jenny actually sent a letter
to the fbi
uh to look into the matter because they
had become convinced
by this point that the kids were still
alive somewhere and that had been taken
um j edgar hoover personally
wrote them a letter back and he wrote
and i quote although i would like to be
of service
the matter related appears to be of
local character
and does not come within the
investigative jurisdiction of this
bureau
even though if some of the um sightings
were correct then they had been taken
over state lines which i believe that
would be
fbi jurisdiction would it not if kids
are kidnapped and taken over state lines
yeah fbi yeah i would have thought but i
guess they'd like they didn't want to
[ __ ] with it
what year was this this was 1947 1947
a couple years after
there wasn't much of an fbi in 47. you
know
not really so could have been that it
just wasn't in their priorities
they're like oh they're just kids yeah
who gives a [ __ ] you gotta you can have
other ones yeah they're just kids
we got more important [ __ ] to do
dudes are stealing money we got to worry
about that people are counterfeiting
probably it doesn't seem like i mean
back then it really did seem like they
were more worried about catching bank
robbers yeah like people that kidnapped
kids which just goes to show where the
[ __ ] priorities were yeah
thank you ken just in case i don't catch
you when i get home love you guys we
love you too
the priorities were real different back
in the 40s
yeah women and children kind of weren't
at the top of the [ __ ] part
they didn't really care about that much
well like i said the local authorities
well and the thing about it too is that
you know you're a dude and like your
wife and kids go missing or they die or
whatever and they're just like well you
can get another wife and she can have
more kids
they're just you know they're just
interchangeable yeah
yeah they were in a bible you know book
of joke and [ __ ]
god [ __ ] kill all your family oh my
god i'm gonna give you ten times then
and then we'll just give you a new one
and it'll be fine get you on the next
one yeah which and joe's like oh awesome
yeah like oh yeah it's better than it
ever was
okay cool which he didn't even like that
just blew my mind
i'm like that just goes to show like how
they actually thought of like women and
kids back then
they're just like whatever it's like
one's as good as another one it's not
like
it's just it's not like they're people
or yeah not back then it's still like
that
it was like that when i was in egypt
yeah oh yeah that's that's just better
when thinking
that's why better ones would think that
way i mean you know
they were kind of giving the wife anyway
yeah
they kind of paid you kind of bought the
wife through the
through their dad type of deal yeah it
was yeah it wasn't
like they had actually like met her nah
yeah it's my favorite day
no all right more like uh more like a
part of the livestock
transaction yeah it's part of the farm
sure yeah
which oh that's that's my wife okay yeah
and look the little children how many of
them are real
gotta check that's what's important like
i said how many of them are men
[Laughter]
are the other ones ah the other ones
we'll just we'll just throw those away
we'll start over
well you know got an apologetic you know
and you know gotta be apologetic it was
it was those
thousands of years old those stories
yeah they are people didn't live long
and
you know and they just they were just
telling stories too
that's not based on anything that
happened yeah but like i said it is kind
of interesting too
even even looking back because i've
written about some cases just like from
the early 1900s
and even this one from like the 40s it
really does show
i mean nowadays like if a kid gets
kidnapped like everybody flips out or a
kid gets murdered like everybody flips
out about it but back then it seemed
like it wasn't really all that big a
deal
not really well albert fish said he'd
abduct a kid beat the kid to death
[ __ ] rape him do all that kind of
[ __ ] nobody'd even ask
nobody even look for the kid yeah well i
mean the one that he killed and ate that
his parents
her parents were actually really really
upset but it did really turn out that
he was getting out of the hood though
yeah i mean out of the [ __ ] place
where all the poor people lived
evidently they didn't miss them they're
just like man well i just
i have one i can't even keep track of
them which is like really really sad
yeah but that's well that's how he knew
to [ __ ]
target those ones yeah well if you look
at some of those like dumbbell tenements
you know it's like in new york chicago
back in the very early 1900s i mean
that's looking terrible living
conditions
yeah look like something like you know
a lot where you keep livestock yep you
know
and just people out in the street you
know what i mean
all the kids out in the street and
[ __ ] laundry hanging everywhere to
just you know you know the sanitation
was bad
and uh it'd be really easy to snatch
kids and people
and they just wouldn't be missed i don't
think they're like wait hold on one two
three four five two i'm missing one
you know wait a minute which one's gone
what are their names again yeah yeah
they're all kind of wearing rags and
stuff
like something my damn oliver twist yeah
that's bad
yeah well like i said that's it it's sad
because you know you get these
[ __ ] predators like albert fish and
his they just kind of swoop right in
there and they can take advantage of
that [ __ ] i'm surprised
honestly i'm surprised it didn't happen
more often well it probably did happen
more often i just don't know about yeah
we just don't know about it yeah they
didn't keep records didn't keep records
in law enforcement not the good old days
not biology no we're not
enough really not a city no way no no
way you've been
great good old days of the 1800s was
far away from civilization
far away yeah good old days was out on
the great plains
[ __ ] living on a trail [ __ ] with
the indians and stuff and trading with
indians and you know getting indian
girlfriend or whatever you know you
didn't want to be
in a city i mean farming is hard too but
bad yeah but easier than probably much
easier and better than living in the in
like a tournament in the middle of like
a gross ass
it evidently was more it was a lot
better to be
out in what we would call the wild west
today yeah i mean
the people in those cities read
adventure novels and aspired to go out
there
yeah that that was to to go out there
and
evidently the people that did it you
know they loved it it says good clean
living healthy living you know
women would escape off into the woods
and [ __ ] run off with the indians
like i said i don't blame them yeah no
better than a better life we're gonna
live in that damn dumb bell tenement
you know yeah like with something with
40 million children
pregnant all the time yes like yeah you
never see the husband he's working no
thank you working in some factory for
pennies thank you
you know and he comes back he's just
wasted away from [ __ ] hard labor
hell no you wanted to be the indians
[ __ ] had a much
better lifestyle for that time like i
said the girl they've been here for
thousands of years so it's like they
kind of had their [ __ ] together early
industrial
lifestyle [ __ ] was terrible and
that's why you had guys like
[ __ ] karl marx appear writing about
all that [ __ ] you know what
marx was talking about did apply but
that was back then
and in that stage of development yeah
you know it's [ __ ] miserable
yep yeah well like i said it's kind of
the same conditions that
uh allowed jack the ripper to like run
wild because it was it was white chapel
it's just it was all
prostitutes and criminals and just like
poor people and it's just like no one
you could
kind of [ __ ] kill people and nobody
would even really notice i mean the only
reason people noticed him was because it
was so
egregious and so in your face according
to the writings of the time
europe was even worse than than the
eastern seaboard of america
much worse because of the population
density
you couldn't get away with you couldn't
really get away with it from it
yeah at least if you were on the
american continent you could
[ __ ] get a state coach or [ __ ]
maybe get on a train maybe the train
didn't go all the way out to the eastern
to the western coast but you could walk
out
of the civilization and go live
yeah you couldn't do that in europe you
know what i mean all the countries i was
owned by some good
abilities yeah there was no word you
were trapped you couldn't go anywhere
so you had to live in that ship yeah
here it's like i said it's not like it
was easy
to go and kind of like you know scrape a
life out of the wilderness but it could
be good
you could they did it yeah a lot of the
second uh
wild west characters were europeans that
were
not they hadn't been in the united
states long they hit new york they were
they were like oh [ __ ] this
uh maybe they had some money and bought
some guns and some equipment and just
started to keep go
they just kept going west you know they
made a life out there they were gonna
stay in that [ __ ]
yeah it was just horrible you see the
photographs of it mm-hmm
yeah concrete jungle whatever the name
of that was in that movie no that book
that they
they made us read concrete jungle right
i think it was just called it was
sinclair lewis
i think it was just called the jungle
the jungle yeah i think it was just
called that
yeah i think somebody was talking about
that in the comments
the jungle yeah we read that in high
school i think yeah
what they were doing to the meat and the
meat packing yeah that was all about
that
yeah i read a book a while back
i wish i could remember the name of it i
have to look up on my on my goodreads
shelves but um it was all about
uh food safety laws um you know people
take it for granted nowadays that the
food you buy at the grocery store is you
know
of this 99.99 is it's totally safe yeah
but um
not too long ago no not so much
you were kind of taking your life in
your hands yeah like uh
probably prior i guess prior to world
war ii maybe um
maybe even a little later than that yeah
um
there really wasn't any codified no food
standards
codes like no food standards that said
like how stuff had to be packaged or
you know canned or anything like that so
i mean it was just like a free-for-all
and
it was uh it's pretty horrifying to talk
about they'd have whole sides of beef
that would fall down behind racks
and get and get trapped back there and
forgotten for weeks and they'd be rotten
and they'd pull three or four of them
out of there at the end of the week you
know
and or end of the month and they pull
them out there and there'd be these
[ __ ]
moldy milky stinky [ __ ]
sides of beef and then the management
was like no we're gonna put that in the
can we're gonna can that [ __ ]
yeah because of course they're like what
and they would cover it with lye and
nowadays you would get food and try to
they try to kill the bacteria in that
thing
and then throw that in the damn
centrifuge and
grind it up boil it put it in a can
along with the rest of the good meat
they didn't give a [ __ ] they did not
give a [ __ ] so they said some of those
cans you'd open them up and they'd
already be rotten
yeah just be rotten and the guys would
eat it anyway just looking terrible
dan says why does the book about food
safety laws sound really really boring
it really wasn't though
it really wasn't um because the 1800s
was bad there's a lot to [ __ ] talk
about it was i wish i could remember the
name of it like i said i'll have to look
it up and like uh
say it on one of the other things but i
checked out the library a couple years
ago and it was
fascinating i love books about the
history of stuff that i
never thought about the history they had
one of the meat packing plants
had this procedure where they'd throw
sides of beef
into scalding hot water and it would
loosen the the the skin
off of the damn things and they'd pull
the skin off and
anyway guys were falling into these vats
mm-hmm
along with the footage like oh well
extra person like we can't we're not
stopping the process just so i can keep
it going
and the dude would get packed along with
the beef life was cheap
yeah and they just so some of those cans
you know have
dudes would be in there dude meat would
be in there usd
dude mate yeah usda dude me this tastes
like earl
[Laughter]
100 certified honky
you have d.a choice
peck of wood i mean did you guys
if you guys are watching my book review
uh [ __ ] i
just talked about a book a couple uh
weeks ago called tenders the flesh
and it was about that exact thing where
all the animals had died out from like a
virus and you couldn't eat animals
anymore so they started breeding humans
for meat and they started um
slaughtering them just like
animals were slaughtered and usually the
book was
yeah the book the book is actually like
pretty horrifying
yeah the aztecs did that spanish spanish
to find these prisons and they were
fattening up dudes in there
because be sacrificed they'd eat them
yeah that's what this book is about you
like i said it's pretty [ __ ] gross
it's uh i can't remember the name of the
author she's venezuelan i think
but yeah it's called tender as the flesh
that's a translation but it's it's a
really really good book but
oh man it's pretty it's pretty refereed
gotta say
um so yeah where was i okay so they get
the letter from j
edgar hoover being like nah bro don't
bother me with that local [ __ ] i don't
even care
um about five kids like i said now the
thing about it though was that it seemed
like
some of the fbi agents were actually
really willing to help out
but he said hey you know we'll help you
out if you we can get like all your
local authorities to like you know
work with us on this interestingly uh
the local authorities didn't want to
[ __ ] with it they're just like
nah we're just gonna they die in the
fire you know it's
that's the end of the matter that's
pretty much all they you know was it was
faulty wiring
kids died in the fire at the end so
that's kind of where they were with it
so at this point like i said you got to
get like george and jenny
sotter i you know i can't blame them
it's like five
of their [ __ ] children are either
dead or missing
and the fire like i said more and more
looking like arson
so they are just not going to let this
[ __ ] go which like i said
if your parents you know people can
relate
so at this point fbi isn't going to help
them local authorities don't want to
help them so
they hire a private investigator tina
then she added the jungle to her book
list you go love that one
they made they made me read that in uh
military school we were
yeah i read it in high school sinclair
lewis um
it's again pretty horrifying but like i
said just the whole history
i don't know why i just have this really
fascinating like i'm
i like history anyway but i really like
books that are like a history of [ __ ]
that i never thought
the history would be interesting you
know what i mean i bring this up a lot
but
one of my favorite books that i ever
read like nonfiction was called the
perfect red and it was about
the beetle that they crushed their
little carapaces to make that really
beautiful like red dye out of like in
the middle ages or whatever it was
and you would think that that book would
be super boring but it was not there was
[ __ ]
pirates and wars and all kind of [ __ ] in
this book like because
the trade in this beetle and this die
was so lucrative that you had like all
this [ __ ]
piracy and all kind of [ __ ] going on
with it was just like [ __ ]
fascinating
i have read at least five or six books
about the history of coffee
okay so there you go it sounds like it'd
be really boring but it's really really
not i mean there's just
i i read books about the history of
coffee i've read books about the history
of
smallpox vaccines i've read like all
kinds of [ __ ] like that
i don't know why there's just a it's a
very specific niche
kind of history book where it's like hey
here's a thing that you always thought
was super mundane and boring but
actually it's like really fascinating
i love that kind of [ __ ] if you write a
book like that i just totally want to
read it
but yeah so they hire a private
investigator the private investigator's
name was cc
tinsley now one of the things that
good old cc tinsley uncovered was that
remember that insurance salesman who
came to the house and tried to
sell george sodder some life insurance
and georgetown was like yeah no thanks i
don't need any and then he was like
yeah your [ __ ] goddamn house is gonna
go up and smoke you know quote unquote
okay so tinsley found out that that dude
was uh not i don't know if he was really
an insurance salesman
but he happened to be on the coroner's
jury
that had found the fire accidental
suspicious um also
there was a another guy he was going
around like interviewing like a lot of
people in fayetteville
and there was a minister in fayetteville
and he told uh tinsley a very
interesting story about fj morris who
was the fire chief
of fayetteville uh west virginia i
almost said new jersey i don't know why
so this is this is super weird i don't i
don't even know why this happened
but so fj morris had said very clearly
uh no remains were found
in the um you know the remains of the
house
the burned house but he did tell this
minister
for whatever reason that he found a
heart
in the ashes he's like so i found this
heart
and i put it in a box and i buried it
at the scene because i thought that
oh maybe it'll give the family some
closure but he didn't tell the family
that he found a heart there right and
this gets weirder too
so tinsley is finally goes to the fire
chief is like bro what the [ __ ]
you found a heart where is it so
fj morris goes to the spot
and they dig it up they dig up the box
and they take the supposed heart to the
funeral director
in town and the funeral director said
this isn't a heart
this is a beef liver so the fire chief
put a beef liver in a box and
buried it at the site of the fire
damn like you do like what the [ __ ] this
is just like so weird to me
uh and honestly and he probably did it
like way after the fire because it
wasn't burned or anything like that
like the the beef liver wasn't burned so
it's obviously it wasn't a heart it
wasn't
so i'm thinking that the weird thing is
that it seemed like the fire chief
wanted to
um you know i i kind of feel like he was
maybe
in on it but he's like well i want to
have like a body part in there so it
doesn't seem so weird that there's no
body parts but then he didn't tell the
family he's like hey i found a heart you
know what i mean which like you'd think
that he would
and you'd think too that he'd be smart
enough to like at least try to burn it
so it looked like a burned hey i found
part of your kid
but he didn't even burn it he just took
like a piece of beef liver like out of
his [ __ ]
icebox or whatever and put it in a box
and like barry is like what the [ __ ] was
he even thinking i don't know
do you want that side do you want to go
outside does she have her little she
looks like she wants yeah she wants
does she have a little clothes on okay
her clothes
it's just it's her little reflective
collar she's only allowed to go in the
backyard if she has the reflective
collar on but i call her her clothes i
don't know why
but yeah so i don't know that
this is one of the weirdest like aspects
of this to me because it seems like
you can kind of like know the motivation
for why he did it but then like
he just kind of [ __ ] up the motivation
because he didn't tell the family about
it and he didn't burn it he didn't try
to make it look like it had been in the
fire or anything like that so it was
like super weird
so at this stage i mean maybe he thought
that
them just like finding it would like
make them just call the whole thing off
and like he wouldn't have to worry about
it anymore i don't know it's just like
really weird
so um at this point like i said george
and jenny
are still like convinced that their kids
are still alive so they're looking for
any leads as to where they might have
gone
um george ended up seeing a
picture in a newspaper of some school
kids in new york city
and he thought that one of them looked
like his daughter
betty um so he drove to manhattan to
try and find out where she was but the
parents
uh wouldn't talk to him now
in august of 1949 george and jenny
decided they were going to mount a new
search
uh at the fire scene uh which like i
said had been bulldozed over but you
know they
it there was still like [ __ ] there there
was still buried stuff there he just
like put dirt over the top of it and
like planted flowers and whatnot
so they bring in this pathologist from
washington dc
named oscar hunter um they so they
escape
excavated the whole site at this point
uh
they found some coins that had been kind
of burned
um they found a partly burned dictionary
which to me
seems significant because if a book
didn't even burn entirely then
there's no way that that fire was enough
to have consumed five entire bodies with
no trace left at all i mean it's a book
it's made of [ __ ] paper
so they did find like a dictionary that
was partially burned
now during this excavation interestingly
they found a few pieces of what looked
like
a human vertebrae at which point
for a second they were just kind of like
oh well here are some bones
you know maybe this will lead to you
know a solution of the mystery or
whatever
she wouldn't go outside well that's okay
but um
i asked those people across the street
they're out in front asking if that grey
cat was theirs they said no
hmm so that cat doesn't live over there
maybe is she
she can't be a stray she's gotta belong
to somebody maybe i gotta put a collar
on that cat put a message on the collar
maybe like whose cat is this yeah cause
if she's not anybody's cat i'm
kidnapping her
then we'll have three cats i've been
watching
for the last few nights i've been i
found this uh we found this channel on
youtube what is it called flatbush cats
and it's about this couple in brooklyn
and uh they try to well there's like a
whole bunch of you know homeless and
abandoned cats like in brooklyn
and so they try to uh the adult ones
they try to trap them and
you know spay and neuter them and then
they let them because a lot of them are
feral so they won't live in a house
so but they at least try to spay and
neuter them so they don't reproduce
but the ones that are kittens that are
still young enough they will usually
trap them
and socialize them and then foster them
out and like try to get them adopted
so they have a whole channel and they
you know have each little episode is
like about a different kitty that they
found
and it's you know that i i started
watching i was watching a bunch of them
last night but
there's a couple that they have that
they say like right out front they're
like well this one has kind of a sad
ending and i'm like nope
i just have to skip it i only want to
see the happy ones i can't i can't stand
it
like the cat stuff that's bad but yeah
if
i mean if her little friend doesn't have
a little home then i
i think we might have to give her a
little home because already
pookie likes this kitty i don't know if
it's a boy or a girl
they're little buddies although we
suspect
that this mysterious kitty got in a
fight with beijing
we don't know for sure but
we did find like beijing had a couple of
little scratches right and like
little tufts of hair that we found like
on the driveway
so i don't know if she got in a fight
with this other kitty
because her and her and pookie kind of
fight but not like fight fight they just
kind of play fight they just kind of
hiss at each other and
yeah you suck no you suck but i don't
know so this other cat might be
friends with pookie but not so much of
beijing i don't know
so uh so these vertebrae that they found
at the site
they send them to the smithsonian right
and they're like okay figure this [ __ ]
out
because for a minute they thought that
maybe this was some of the bones they
were looking for it's like oh mystery
solved you know even though most of the
bodies are burned like obviously
you know it here's at least one of the
remains however the smithsonian said
uh the human bones this was the report
that they issued the human bones consist
of four
lumbar vertebrae belonging to one
individual
um they said that because the uh
there's there was some kind of fusion
going on in there like the transverse
recesses they call it
are fused um so this individual when
they died was probably 16 or 17
years old could be as old as 22.
however the oldest missing child
that was presumably still in the house
when the fire broke out was
14. so it's very very unlikely
that these bones uh and also one you
know
one they were too old two they weren't
burned um so these bones probably
uh most likely did not belong to any of
the missing solder
children um you know like i said not
impossible
but unlikely um so
they kept looking through it again it's
like they found no other bones other
than these four vertebrae like i said
that weren't even
burned and belonged to someone
presumably much
older um and even at the smithsonian
they're like yeah um
these kids were probably not in this
house because you would have found
the full skeletons i mean even after a
fire of that
you know heat and duration it's like you
should have found at least four
uh five skeletons and nothing was found
so uh they thought that probably the
bones had come from
the dirt that george used to kind of
go over the site you know what i mean
when he bulldozed the whole site over
there like it was probably just mixed in
with that dirt
um you know so it didn't have anything
to do with the fire
now at this point um when the report
from the smithsonian came out
there were two hearings at the capitol
in charleston
and um you would think because there was
new interest like raised in it that
maybe something would get done however
uh the governor of charleston and the
state police superintendent
they both pretty much told the sodders i
don't know if to their faces
or what but they just said um well their
search is
hopeless and the case is closed
basically
they were like even though we found no
evidence that your kids are dead your
kids are dead
shut up and go away i mean essentially
that's what they told them
so it was at this point that george and
jenny put up their
billboard along route 16. they started
passing out flyers
offering a 5 000 reward for information
leading to
uh recovery of their children hopefully
still alive
uh the amount was soon increased to ten
thousand dollars
now they started getting a bunch of tips
every single one of these
uh george sodder went and checked out he
got a letter from a woman in st
louis who said that the oldest girl
martha was in a convent there
he went check that out but i guess it
wasn't her there was another tip that
came from texas
um somebody said that they had overheard
somebody in a bar talking about a weird
fire on christmas eve in west virginia
um also somebody in florida said that
the kids
were staying with a distant relative of
uh jenny sauders
and uh george checked out every single
one of these but could not
uh you know find any evidence that any
of them were his
children that were still alive now
interestingly in 1968
and uh if you're counting this is more
than 20 years after the fire 23 years
after the fire
uh jenny finds a letter in the mail
and it was addressed only to her what
not to george
was addressed to jenny sotter it was
postmarked in kentucky
but didn't have a return address
inside of the envelope there was a
picture of a man
in his mid-20s on the back of the photo
there was something written on there it
said
louis sotter i love brother frankie
little boys a 90132
or could have been three five not real
sure because the handwriting is kind of
messy
now when they looked at this picture it
really does look
a lot like their son lewis now at the
time of the fire he was nine years old
so the age would have been about right
uh he would have been you know 23 years
older
um he had the same uh eyes the same
color hair
i have seen some um some people online
because this is a pretty
like uh common case like for web salutes
and stuff like that like kind of looking
at all the stuff
some people have done um i can't
remember what it's called but it's that
it's that app where you can
compare like a kid's face to an adult's
face to see if like that's them
so somebody did that and uh determined
that it was like
[ __ ] like 84 or 95
or something like that that it was
probably the same person because they
had a picture
of lewis when he was nine years old and
uh the picture that
jenny sodder had been sent 23 years
later
it i have to say it does look creepily
like the same dude
so i'm not really sure like i don't
think there was a letter or anything
else it was just this picture and this
weird message that was on the back
so some people have said that maybe um
the letters and numbers on there was
maybe it was a zip code or something
like that like they were trying to
tell her what you know they were trying
to like tell her coated like where they
were like maybe they were in some kind
of trouble
not really sure um the weird thing about
this too and i feel like this hasn't
gone into enough
so they hire another private
investigator to go check this lead out
so they send him to kentucky
that private investigator
apparently went to kentucky to check out
the case and then they never heard from
him again
he so he disappeared weird um
and i'm presuming because some people
are like well did he just like run off
with their money but
i was like he was a private investigator
it's not like they gave him a [ __ ]
million dollars or anything like that he
was just like whoo i'm going to the
bahamas
like where did he go they never heard
from him again he's maybe something he
ran a foul something maybe
that's kind of what people are implying
or
a better case came by yeah he was just
like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that case maybe maybe i don't know
so yeah really strange so that so that
[ __ ] dude disappeared
um so they figured okay so they're like
when that happened they were like okay
now if we publish this envelope or the
name of the town on the postmark
um you know maybe that'll blow back like
if that is their son like maybe
someone's holding him against his will
and it's like maybe they'll kill him
it's like you know they were really
suspicious at this point
so they're like basically what they did
was they took the billboard that they
already had
and they updated the billboard like they
put that new picture on it like just in
case
um you know what i mean so they did that
um
basically at this point you know george
and jenny are not
spring chickens anymore um you know it's
been more than two decades since the
kids had disappeared they still don't
know
uh where they are and the sad thing was
that
um about a year after they got that
letter not even a year after they got
that picture
um george died so he never did find out
like what happened to them if that was
really lewis or anything
um basically it's just kind of like
and at that stage jenny sotter really
didn't know what else she
still kept on like looking for the kids
they said that she just wore
like morning clothes like for the rest
of her [ __ ] life which is
like [ __ ] sad she didn't die until
1989. um
at which point you know they weren't
allowed around to pay for the billboard
anymore so i guess the billboard's not
there anymore it was uh taken down in
1989 but it was there
for like i said in more than more than
40 years
um now her surviving children
i believe only one of them is still
alive as of this recording
um but so her kids and grandkids
still kept looking for their siblings
you know just over the years it was kind
of like an obsession with them
and i guess it's like the thing about it
i guess some of their kids even said
that like they they had even had like
organized crime people like come up to
them like try to recruit them and [ __ ]
um try to extort money out of them
um they really seem to
genuinely believe that the kids were
kidnapped before the fire was started
obviously it really does seem like the
fire was arson
um you know like i said there was a dude
that stole the block and tackle the
ladder was in a place where it wasn't
supposed to be
the phone lines appeared as though they
had been cut um
you know there was that whole thing
where she heard the thing rolling down
the roof and then later they found that
rubber ball in there that looked like a
pineapple bomb or an incendiary device
so it did really seem like and also
there was a witness too there was a bus
driver i think that was going past the
house
um prior to the fire breaking out
and said that they saw somebody throwing
what looked like molotov cocktails or
you know fire bombs or something like
that at their house
so it definitely does seem like there
was some kind of
conspiracy against this particular
family maybe against george sotter in
particular because it really does seem
like the fire was
arson but whether the kids were in there
or not no one is entirely sure like some
people are kind of like yeah maybe the
kids just died and it was just weird
they never did find the bodies
but i don't know it just seems really
both scenarios seem unlikely right they
would at least found a skull
you would think that you would at least
think they'd find something
they found nothing yeah they found no
teeth they found nothing nothing nothing
so it's just
that to me seems unlikely it is also
unlikely that someone managed to get
five kids out of the house
without anyone noticing it but
i don't know i've done before yeah and
both scenarios seem equally unlikely but
i think the fact that they just found
zero evidence of any of five children
that were in a house that supposedly
burned up and they found nothing in
there i think the kids were taken out
before the fire
was set you know what i mean yeah
maybe one of the kids did it but they
would have found them eventually well
yeah but these were like little kids the
oldest
the oldest one was 14. they were little
you know what i mean
that's old enough to start a fire but
the thing is though is if the if the 14
year old or the younger ones had started
the fire
and then they got all the kids out and
tried to run away they'd have been found
eventually
yeah that means they were never found i
mean like i said they would probably all
be dead
by now because honestly um i was reading
an interview
with sylvia who was only two years old
when the fire started
in 2012 she was 69 years old and i think
she's the last
remaining one all the other ones are
dead it's only two possibilities
they were kidnapped and the arson was
used to cover it up
yeah or they died in an anomalous fire
that totally consumed their skeletons
i find that hard to believe yeah i kind
of felt
that you couldn't find any of those yeah
they found nothing
and it really did seem like a lot of
stuff too like the fire chief and
everything like that it seemed like they
were trying to like cover some [ __ ] up
i'm not usually a big like conspiracy
theory thing person but this does
actually seem like a little bit of a
little
conspiracy unless it was a shitty
investigation that they found the bones
but they didn't realize that they found
the bones
yeah i mean yeah i mean like if they
found the bones but they just thought it
was charred wood you know maybe
something like that but you would think
that they would know the difference
i mean it's up on the second floor the
house goes up the second floor collapses
in on the first one
so it gets kind of mixed up but you're
gonna find skulls
come on you're gonna find at least teeth
or something yeah
and the thing about it is that you know
if
the if the fire was arson which i
imagine it probably was
um you would think that
it seemed like the fire chief and you
know the sheriff everybody that
investigated this were very
invested in making the sodders believe
that all their kids had died in the fire
so you'd think
that you know any little thing that they
found and they'd be like yeah look here
here they are so the fact that they
didn't find
anything in there even though they
probably had
reason to you know had motivation
to find that is just very strange to me
now read what sophie said yeah i was
just gonna say that sophie said i heard
a theory that because george raised the
grounds of the house right after
somehow the soil underneath could have
still been smoldering enough to burn up
the bones
has someone tested this theory i mean
you know that's possible like i said i'm
not sure how long
it was um when he because they actually
did come and do an investigation and
like go through the ruins and stuff
but um i think it was at least two days
before he raised it over
but i don't i just don't know if there'd
be enough heat because like i said you
really have to have a lot of heat and it
has to be like
sustained over a really long period of
time before you get
like nothing left i'm not saying it's
impossible i'm just saying i don't know
and then they did an excavation later
and also didn't find anything
so and i just find that very strange
sort of died of smoke inhalation
first well yeah five of them you think
that
at least one of them would have woke up
there and all that
well yeah like i said you were trying to
get the other ones up and what's
interesting too
is that none of them seem to have been
awakened by the phone ringing
like i said because jenny had to get the
phone ringing woke her up
at like 12 30. now what happened with
the ladder well the latter they found it
later yeah but it was like in a ditch
like a little way off the property like
like somebody had because george was
like i you know
how did that get over there he always
kept it leaned up against the side of
the house
always and the fact that somebody and
like i said somebody had seen somebody
stealing the blocking tackle out of the
garage
either one of the neither one of the
trucks would start it's just like there
was all kind of weird [ __ ] going on
there's another third possibility
one of those parents killed the kids and
then set the fire to hide the murder
some people have said that but again
never in there
but again it's like it just seems like
they spent the whole rest of their lives
trying to find those kids and spending
all their money on
private investigators and billboards and
[ __ ] like that
it seems unlikely that they would do
that if they had been the ones to kill i
have heard like a couple people suggest
that but
there were there just seemed like there
would be no motive that was like and
their other four kids
that you know all got out it wasn't like
and those were these are
how many of them actually were missing
five the four made it out
four made it out and then and they had
one more uh
kid but he was in the army so he was
away okay but they were up in the
top in the top floor they were on the
second floor on the second floor
yeah they didn't see the other kids
no because what i guess what ended up
happening was that
those the five kids that burned up they
had stayed up late
because they wanted to play with their
christmas presents and
so the parents and the older kids had
gone to bed
yeah um you know and they were like yeah
just turn everything off you know
and lock the door and [ __ ] before you go
to bed but then when the phone rang and
woke jenny up and she came out
she saw marion who was 17. she lived she
was asleep on the couch but she had
fallen asleep so she didn't know she
didn't see where the kids had gone
she just assumed they had gone up to
their rooms you know they had two rooms
like on either end of the hallway
i think that's that's that was my
understanding from like this they must
have been burned up
in there and it was a bad
investigation they found the bones and
didn't realize they found the bones or
like you said we got churned up in the
ground they smoldered away
like what sophie's possible like i said
but
i don't know it just seems really really
weird to me this case has always seemed
really weird to me
and some people have said too if it
wasn't an anomaly i think it might have
been bad
bad investigative techniques maybe
possibly too
and like i said it was kind of a cluster
[ __ ] because it was like christmas eve
and like none of the [ __ ]
it seemed like none of the phone [ __ ]
was working like the operator wasn't
picking up and
all the firefighters weren't there the
fire chief was like i don't know how to
drive the truck you've got to wait till
somebody gets here with the bodies must
have been there but they didn't find
them
i don't know man though it's like it fee
it's unlikely that they would not find a
single trace
of five [ __ ] bucks up on the top
floor when the top four collapsed it got
mixed in with every but everything else
and by the morning
by the time the morning came they had
kind of smoldered away
well like i said i i think that you
didn't uh i think you weren't in here
when i said when they did the excavation
later
yeah they found a partially burned
dictionary
that had been in the house so it's like
the fact that a dictionary didn't
entirely burn
yeah leads me to believe that the bodies
wouldn't have entirely burned either
well that's weird because that kind of
takes me back to
the spontaneous human combustion theory
you'll find a body totally consumed no
bones or anything
and then it'll be in a room or be
sitting on a bed or in a chair and the
legs will be
or the feet will be totally intact and
you know
there won't be any damage in the room
but the [ __ ] body totally consumed
and it does look like intense heat it
doomed the body quickly
you know a fire from within and all that
that's not what
i remember being fascinated with that
kind of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when you actually see it it's somebody
had a heart attack a cigarette in their
hand and their clothes caught on fire
and then the burning clothes ignites the
fat on the body
and the person can't handle it over
a long period of time and you that you
can actually recreate it with a pig
put a pig there and [ __ ] put a little
bit of yeah i saw a documentary where
they did that actually
you got to put it like on a carpet or
something where there's an airflow
underneath it
like a carpet or a chair and then you
have a little bit of cloth on top of it
and the flames never get three or four
inches tall
little bitty flames and it's not big it
just burns down the body like a fuse
so not all the bodies burning at once
yeah little by little maybe it was a
situation like that
where yeah possible that fire wasn't hot
you know it wasn't very hot but it
burned for a long period of time
maybe those kids that were kind of fat
and there was enough fat on them i don't
know it was nice to get 45.
well we don't know they didn't look bad
for some reason there are photos of them
maybe for some reason there was
enough air flow to keep them burning
like a candle
yeah sure that's possible so there was a
wick effect
because when you see the body the
spontaneous with the so-called
spontaneous combustion bodies
it does look like everything's consumed
except the feet
yeah the feet don't burn because they're
pretty lean
not a lot of fat not a lot of fat on the
feet yeah
it's weird it is weird and i'm not
saying that that's not a possibility i
mean
obviously i don't know that's why this
case is so fascinating to people and a
lot of people too are like they're kind
of like well
like i said you know it's a mystery what
happened to the kids and it's also a
mystery like who set the [ __ ] fire
um which like i said it seems like
there's a lot of circumstantial evidence
pointing to the fact that it was
probably arson
uh you know just just my uh theory about
it
but they're kind of like well were the
kids in the house or not
it's like if the kids were kidnapped how
did they get out of the house before
the fire started and some people have
pointed out you know one of the chores
that they were supposed to do
before they went to bed and that jenny
told them to do
um you know she's let them stay up late
but she's like okay well before you go
to bed like do this this and this
one of the things they were supposed to
do was go out to the uh
barn or the out building and take care
of the farm animals
so some people have have suspected maybe
all the kids went out there to take care
of the farm animals and they got taken
out there because like i said there were
some other people wondering about their
[ __ ] property that night
because somebody stole that block tried
to steal that block and tackle and
somebody moved that [ __ ] ladder
and somebody cut their phone lines
reportedly
so there was somebody on their property
that night so
if the kids were outside if they had
gone outside to
do one of their chores maybe they got
taken then maybe it was somebody they
knew
so you know maybe that he was just like
oh hey your parents said come with me
like we're going for a ride or we're
going to go see santa or
i don't know and like maybe they went
with them in a car
when granthars said yeah i was uh i was
a criminal investigator for 18 years my
27-year law enforcement career bad
investigations do happen because
investigators are human oh yeah
you know it could have been too and
because this was so long ago they didn't
have the forensic
science technology even now we have that
now and like people still [ __ ] [ __ ] up
all the time
you might have seen it as a simple house
fire they were
they weren't real inquisitive about it
so they didn't put a bunch of
effort in it oh yeah they burned up yeah
and a story and a story but like i said
it really did seem like it was at least
an arson and you'd think they'd at least
try to solve that but they didn't really
try to it seemed like they were
kind of getting stonewalled on who had
caused the fire like they came in
immediately like oh you know must been
electrical
[ __ ] maybe the kids did it by accident
something like that
although like i said they did find that
thing that looked like an incendiary
device
and and somebody saw somebody uh
reported later that they had seen
somebody throwing what looked like
molotov cocktails at their house
that night so it does seem like
yeah that could have been scuttlebutt
could have been it was a bus driver that
said that he was going by like on
christmas eve and he said he thought he
saw people more than one person
like throwing fire bombs or molotov
cocktails or something like that in the
direction of the house
he's talking back to the fascist uh the
italian fascist
angle it seems like that's kind of like
um the going theory if the kids have
been kidnapped if the fire was an
arson most people are saying it was
probably because of like
george's anti-mussolini sentiment and
maybe some
people didn't like what he was talking
about they just said they were going to
like take care of them i guess i don't
know maybe some people are like really
sensitive about that i don't know like i
said
well that's why people are still talking
about this case because
it's just it's so weird and anomalous
and there's like all these really weird
little details like all those weird
people that like turn up at his house
beforehand like
you know oh that could cause a fire
someday like saying [ __ ] like that
um well yeah but he was the source
really specific threat
sure yeah true and you got a guy who's
kind of paranoid well some of it well
a couple of his sons um had heard it as
well uh
and they like reported like some
weird-ass behavior and they and they
sounded like coincidence maybe but the
sons had seen somebody like watching
the younger kids coming home from school
like parked down the side of the road
like watching the kids
so don't know
most likely it was an accidental fire
and the kids were burned up and it was a
bad investigation
and they didn't find them that's the
most likely
but i think that's most likely yeah but
we're not saying that it couldn't have
been something that could have been
something else but i'm saying that you
know i think
i think the most likely is an accidental
fire
possible it's possible yeah a lot of
things are possible
i don't know like i said i'm not a big
conspiracy theory person but this one
i don't know yeah occam's razor would
say
probably it was just a fire and they
died and it was like tragic
but i don't know there's so many weird
little details about it that kind of
made me think man maybe they can find a
lot of weird details though in hindsight
true i mean it wouldn't be that weird
for somebody to like burn somebody
else's house down because they were mad
that's not that weird
maybe they didn't he doesn't seem to be
a target though
politics wasn't enough i don't think but
i know that's just
just me that's just what i think maybe
i don't know yeah seth is saying even
with bad investigating five bodies and
no trace of any just makes me think the
kids were not there
that's kind of it's like you know that's
kind of what i'm leaning forward too it
just seems really really weird to me
that they didn't find any
sign or it's not a single tooth not
anything i'd i'd agree with you says if
i had confidence in the investigation
i have a feeling that the investigation
was bad
that's what i think yeah possibly
it's more likely that the investigation
was bad
and that they did find the bodies they
just didn't know it because they were
just
yeah because they had become turned into
[ __ ] dust you know they were burned
to a char
you know they fell into fragments yeah
the temperature was just right
there was enough air flow air flow
yeah airflow yeah
but yeah it's a it's a scary case what's
the one i've been wanting to cover for a
long time like i said i wrote about my
book a little bit
um so you want to talk about something
else because i see usually you tell me
to like over prepare
um oh no this is no it's perfect but uh
yeah so i only had one
yeah i only had one case to talk about
this when i got through it before i'm
even
all that drunk no it's perfect and we
all lose the strength and we've only
been on for two hours
that's about we need to go for like
another no that's good no two hours is
good for the [ __ ] show
but yeah yeah like you said we haven't
lost the stream we haven't lost a stream
[ __ ] it was that long
maybe it was those lights maybe we're
just like sucking up too much [ __ ]
because all that [ __ ] motion going on
in the background
i don't know i'm just now i'm like
scared to like wave my i don't know wait
my arms around
no all right please don't do that i'll
get frustrated
you know what i mean but yeah so let's
see what is everybody what does
everybody think about this case what do
you think
happened uh yeah houses were built all
out of wood
which you know but see that's another
thing i don't think wood fires get hot
enough
to burn a body up to nothing a lot of it
has to do with the airflow
yeah okay people are always talking
about well these fires don't get hot
enough
a coal fire all right if you have a
bellows
is hot enough to make steel with
okay you just have to have enough air
flow on it
that's the air is the fuel not so much
the fire not so much the wood
at that point and they're up on the
second floor
so the heat can suck in an air current
underneath it
and pull it upstairs so you've got a
wind a hot wind blowing into the fire
from the bottom
and get real hot like a racket
for some reason when sophie was talking
about the churned up soil creating a
heat pocket underground i thought of uh
centralia pennsylvania yeah how long has
that
fire been burning it's still burning i
don't know well i know it is but when
did it start
the 50s i think one like 16.
remember like we watched a dan bell
video about he went to centralia
pennsylvania that's kind of like famous
for being i think it's
mostly abandoned now yeah it's at least
50 years but yeah it's been it's like an
underground fire it's been burning there
i feel like all that time
which is [ __ ] crazy to think they'll
go into houses in the outskirts that
have been
abandoned forever creepy yeah
they're still they're still furnished
some of the stuff was furnished from the
uh
late 80s early 90s which i don't
understand that yeah
but uh i guess they moved people out of
there afterwards
because he was in there [ __ ] there
was a vhs
there was a there's a vcr in there with
a bunch of vhs tapes and movies
no power though yeah i was uh
i was watching one last night it was
like some kind of
children's hospital like a children's
like with kids with disabilities
and i think it had closed in the 90s um
and i'm every time he goes in places
like that
every time you see like a vcr with like
videotapes i'm always kind of like
looking to see what [ __ ] movies those
are
yeah movies you forgot about
it's like what were these kids watching
in this [ __ ] he spent sure a pet
detective
that's funny that was the first one you
thought of yeah the mask
oh god crap like that [ __ ] jim carrey
man
it can't be a jim carrey movie yeah you
know what the sad thing about jim carrey
is
is that it in a lot of ways he's kind of
like adam sandler in that when you give
him like a serious dramatic role
he's actually a really good actor jim
carrey is
but i can't stand when he's in like a
comedy role it's just that [ __ ] is just
too it's too much man i don't like any
of those dudes i don't like that dude
i mean uh i don't like your i don't like
hollywood celebrities
the more i find out about them on a
personal level and more i
[ __ ] hear about what happens in
hollywood or or what used to happen in
hollywood hollywood's falling apart now
just the more i found out about that
culture the less i want anything to do
with that [ __ ] i don't like those people
but like i said but like i said all i
was saying was that he's one of those
dudes where
you know [ __ ] like ace ventura on the
mask and [ __ ] like that even when he
played the riddler
it's like i can't really stand it
because it's just too much but when he's
in
a dramatic role like uh eternal sunshine
and spotless mind for example
um or even the truman show which was
kind of funny but more like um
less comedic he's actually like really
good like i said just like adam sandler
i don't really like a lot of his
comedy movies um because it's just like
really
crass and infantile yeah but when he's
in something like
uncut gems or spanglish or something
like that
um he's actually like a really good
actor it's it's really interesting how
we were talking about this when we were
talking about one hour photo because we
were talking about robin williams
it's interesting how a lot of these
comedians especially ones that are super
over the top because robert williams was
like [ __ ] he would now he was
actually funny but he was like really
over the top and coked out all the time
but if you gave him a dramatic role he
was like amazing in it
that's really interesting that
juxtaposition robin williams is actually
pretty dark
yeah from what i understand personally
he's a pretty dark human
oh and everything so so jim carrey jim
carrey's supposed to be just a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
just you just can't stand to be around
him i can see it yeah he just
you know can't keep a woman evidently
either
he just drives him [ __ ] crazy i can
see that too extremely cruel
i i just i don't like hollywood
celebrities the old school ones
at all you know just down
everything you find out about them
they're bad um
and they hate you you know they see you
as
a peasant or a peon and uh they're
better than you and on another level in
and you know
i'm kind of happy that those old schools
top-down systems are vanishing because
you got to look at it this way
they made lots and lots of money
commanding a lot of attention out of a
very narrow bandwidth which is just
film and [ __ ] cable tv
they just commanded a lot more attention
than they really deserved to
you can go on youtube and find guys that
are far more talented
and they're really being who they are
look at the guys from
from [ __ ] blame society i mean i love
that [ __ ] you know
i just watched the one today they were
playing
i love beer and board games and i love
welcome to the basement
there's a two they have a couple other
shows too but those are the ones i watch
most often
the one they put up earlier they were
playing a game
called secret crush and the guy that
invented it was on there playing it with
them
he got the idea because remember all
those like cheesy ass like 90s board
games that were all like for girls
you know what i mean like they were kind
of like mall madness and all that kind
of [ __ ]
he wanted to make a game that was like
that but like for the modern era so it's
kind of like a little bit ironic
and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny also
that that show too they were doing like
a pajama party so everybody had like one
of them had like [ __ ]
like a little like mask of like stuff on
his face and they all jam
thanks for the compliment t what are you
saying oh
my kind of celebs um
are we celebs where does it work we're
not stubborn no we're just like
celebrities we're just in my office like
talking like you would normally talk
but no i i respect [ __ ] well-known
youtube
i i respect youtube famous more than
hollywood famous hollywood famous even
though i like movie stars
i do like them i'm going to say that you
know there are certain things about them
i like but
that era is kind of gone now um and
there were certain ones that i liked
i i like youtube famous better you know
there are guys that i [ __ ] i watch on
youtube i just think they're [ __ ]
great
because they're working on their own
that's who they are
yeah they're not trying to be something
yeah yeah they're not trying to be
something they're not
you know like look at um look at our boy
from [ __ ] [ __ ] k
cinema i love that dude he's just some
dude in the [ __ ] council's stake over
somewhere
giant [ __ ] case and he's [ __ ]
hilarious and it's like he is
his [ __ ] like his camera's not even that
good like the audio is not even that
good he's going to give a [ __ ] no
it's just like he watches like shitty
like stephen movies in the like talks
about them
and had you taken that dude and gave you
the proper management
and [ __ ] did the proper [ __ ] dick
sucking on the [ __ ] casting couch
he would have been a [ __ ] superstar
in the 80s
he's a writer too i need to get some of
this but he doesn't have to [ __ ] do
all that [ __ ] he just does it on his own
from his house he's just [ __ ] cause
he enjoys it yeah he just enjoys it
[ __ ] case cinema it's just movie reviews
from england this guy's [ __ ]
halloween and like i said it's just so i
love it
well because i love that he talks about
shitty movies and also he doesn't really
care that much about his aesthetic
yeah he's just kind of like he's in his
like [ __ ] council house
with it with a beer yeah yeah and um you
know it's all very ramshackle
yeah and i love it i love it and he's so
[ __ ] funny yeah he's
he's in the hood in england pretty much
yeah him and professor bruce and some of
his other like friends they just make
like shitty because they you know
they're just having a good time they
don't care
and then the guys from blame society
they're kind of like these high-minded
artistic kind of guys i respect their
opinions they're real good at [ __ ]
good writing and they uh have a couple
different channels off their well
they have a couple shows running off
their channel and i'd rather listen to
them than
say like siskel and ebert or you know
even though
i like cisco hebrew i thought they were
good but yeah that old format is gone
um roger ebert you know as annoying
as he could be sometimes um i agree with
his opinion about
95 of the time about 90 some
sometimes he'll like especially horror
movies he wasn't like
as on board with it um but he wasn't as
anti-horror
back then as a lot of critics were
because if you guys remember like people
that were into horror back in the 80s
and [ __ ] like that
every single horror movie that came out
got [ __ ] on by critics yeah
i mean it was just kind of it's not like
that anymore like now critics are
actually watching horror movies just
like you would watch any regular movie
and they're like judging it
by its own uh merits back in the day it
was kind of like
mainstream critics really did not like
horror they would just like pretty much
[ __ ] on everything but
so i will give roger ebert that that
even some of like
the [ __ ] from the 70s like texas
chainsaw massacre and stuff like that he
was like kind of on board with that
like he understood where that [ __ ] was
coming from i you know there are some
about
me growing up through the
70s 80s 90s 2000s
i went through the whole evolution you
know the hollywood thing the howard
stern thing and then
howard stern foot and then youtube came
and i i just [ __ ] was gravitated
towards it
you know in the early 2000s i just
[ __ ] loved it
and it's amazing to me that you there
there are young people today that
grow up seeing youtubers as the way
jenny and i used to see celebrities yeah
that's their celebrity that's how they
sure sophie's just said that you know
she said [ __ ] i like
i like [ __ ] youtube youtubers better
than celebrities
and it was funny because when we first
met sophie we picked her up at the
airport
and she was nervous to meet us she was
nervous to meet us like we were
celebrities and we're like dude we're
just people
that's hilarious yeah but i i was
honored though you know
i was like yeah we're totally not
celebrities and like i said what
you know that's and that's a good thing
it is a good that's a good thing
i mean the show that we do like i said
this is just gonna l dude we get drunk
on this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
um it's only a matter of time before we
get like in
a big fight on this show yeah
it's it's only a matter of time before
that happened yeah but you know what i
mean it hasn't happened so far really
but
um you know it might happen so you know
stay tuned but you've only been in a few
fights in real life that's true we argue
but it's not really a fight but yeah we
don't yeah it's not
bad but yeah so i mean we get drunk on
this show in front of people we probably
say really embarrassing personal [ __ ]
yeah but that's okay though and i mean
and i like
other you know what okay other than you
know shitcase cinema i love dan bell i
love
blame society all their [ __ ] is good you
know whether it's movies or
board games or whatever um there's a
bunch of like i love oliver harper he's
kind of like more
kind of more high-end one like his
editing is really good harper's really
good i love all of them there's a lot of
good
i love massacre a lot of good talent
comes from
england a lot of good youtube talent
from england
and that's you know johnny [ __ ] case and
brandon
well brandon is uh excuse me canada
brandon 10 old is canadian yeah yeah i
was you know the
oliver yeah oliver oliver's oliver
[ __ ] top-notch british guy
well he's made like documentaries and
[ __ ] like that yeah
yeah um and yeah like we were saying
like uh canadians like brandon tennold
he does uh kind of well shitty movies
and good movies but kind of like cult
classic type of movies
and he does he's a big mst fan so he
kind of
does a similar thing where he'll show
like clips of the movies and then like
he'll make jokes about it so he's really
good too
it's really weird because one of my
favorite i got into
like a lot of um horror book review
channels like when i first started
getting back into reading horror fiction
and one of my favorite
girls that does that is uh jordaline
she has a channel called jordaline reads
i think she only has like 3 000
subscribers maybe
she's canadian and she is
adorable she just like kind of she sits
in her apartment
she has a couple cats because every now
and then they jump up on the chair like
just
like pookie does in ours and she talks
about like all the books she's really
into like horror thrillers
and she likes uh manga as well so she
has a couple
shows about that she posts a couple
times a week she is super super cute i
love
that she has she has this weird like
um asmr thing going where she has like
these really really long like fake nails
and she'll like put the book up and then
she goes like that like on the front of
the book and like a lot of people are
really into that
but she's like super cute i just love
like the way she talks and her
recommendations are always like on point
read those two comments from tila
because i want to respond to that uh
jenny you and tom aren't owned by anyone
and not pushing an agenda unlike most
mainstream celebs youtube is giving
space to a new type of celebrity
yeah and just check out the mainstream
celebs trying to get a youtube channel
now
yeah okay i never bothered watching that
but you know what i mean because i
i have my people that i like i have like
all my oh and ryan hollinger he's
another one that i really like movie
review he's irish
i i kind of have an understanding what
celebrities are going through
i i do have formal training in um
the grampians will tell you he's seen so
my shows back when i was in high school
and
you know i i dated [ __ ] a girl who
ended up becoming a
celebrity maryland rice cub she was on
24 that's my ex-girlfriend
um i understand that system i didn't
want anything to do with that system
okay um i rec i know i recognize the
styles and the techniques that they use
it was from another era that's really
what you want to use on stage and in
front of a camera when you're doing
script and you're scripting out this big
elaborate production that's how you want
to be
and uh that kind of production
produces a certain type of celebrity
that only existed back in the day
because
it was a very narrow band media just
what you saw on
film and television that's it there was
no internet
so there was an aloofness to them you
didn't see much of them
you were lucky to see a celebrity maybe
at an awards show your favorite
celebrity you might see them for a few
seconds
taking a drink off of a [ __ ] martini
and maybe they said something to the
person next to them and that was all you
were gonna get that damn celebrity
so you didn't know who they were they
weren't real people
you know and it really all came crashing
home to me
with the whole um johnny depp and amber
thing you know how his ex-wife got this
big
fight yeah yeah and i i kind of vaguely
heard about somebody just mentioned that
they're now trying to get youtube
channels they're trying to humanize
themselves
which is very difficult to do well it's
difficult to do because people
already have a perception of you is like
larger than life and you don't come
across
yeah all the ownership
involved there's a lot of [ __ ] you can't
say and you can't be yourself because
you're not maybe
maybe you're not a good person okay yeah
maybe you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah you
don't want everybody knowing you're a
piece of [ __ ] because nobody will go see
your movie yeah
so you can't [ __ ] be yourself well
depp tried to do a [ __ ] live stream
and i was just amazed how he could not
drop the [ __ ]
character he was full on johnny depp as
the talk show character
in his stream and i was just i felt bad
for him
in a way well it's going to be hard to
turn it off
that's your brand yeah i'm like dude
turn the [ __ ] off
and you're so used to right being that
yeah
that you can't well the thing is is that
that may be all there
is maybe that drops
the mystique is gone and nobody wants to
see your [ __ ] movies anymore
because that may not be you at all
you might be a total douche or a total
dork or a [ __ ] well i think a lot of
them are total [ __ ] so you don't
know who
no i don't think that about deb by all
accounts
johnny depp's a good a good dude and i
think that amber chick was [ __ ] lying
about it maybe she took a dump at his
bed and all kinds of weird [ __ ]
she was that you didn't hear about that
i i vaguely remember i don't read a lot
about yeah and she was accusing him of
all kinds of [ __ ]
he's she's getting hers right now
but just goes to show you but sometimes
[ __ ] be crazy and especially i don't
know
i wasn't there so i so i don't know what
happened
yeah old school celebrity was a
limitation and i'm glad that that's
going away
well do you remember back in the old
days [ __ ] man
okay so listen to this [ __ ] so i wrote
about a couple of murders
like unsolved murders in my book that
happened like back in the 20s and 30s
and this was kind of like the day of the
movie star right like you were a movie
star you were owned by the studio like
even more than nowadays right
so your image was very very buttoned
down like you could only
do or say you had to look a certain way
when you went out
that was just very very constrained so
some [ __ ] happened
like this one dude who was like kind of
like an actor director
he gets murdered in his house he gets
like shot in the [ __ ] back
they find him in his [ __ ] you know
villa or whatever
his you know housekeeper finds him and
crazily enough the [ __ ] um i can't
remember what studio he was with i don't
it was maybe it was paramount i don't
know
i don't know exactly but i think it was
william desmond taylor that was his name
this was 1920s
they came to the house before the cops
got there
and cleaned all the [ __ ] out of his
house they took all the booze out
because it was prohibition
they took out all the love letters that
his like girlfriends had sent him they
took all this [ __ ] out because they
didn't want this [ __ ] getting out
they got there for the cops did you
clean the [ __ ] crime scene
you would not be allowed to do that
nowadays no but back then no you could
do it today
well you brought kind of [ __ ] now yeah
probably but like like i said back date
back then they were a lot more [ __ ]
uh blatant about it okay uh t let's
mention in a couple of people mentioned
keanu reeves uh look
keanu reeves is probably one of the few
big celebrities that could make it as
a youtuber he seems like you know what
he's he's a very cool dude he seems like
a delightful human being the dude
and the reason why he's cool is that
he's uh
he's confident in himself because he
does have real skills uh he can
he's really good with riding motorcycles
and building motorcycles he knows about
engineering and
he has a little motorcycle company and i
saw him
uh talking about motorcycles and he's
just he's just a normal dude
talking about how machines work you know
which you know me being a dude i'm i'm
rocking up on that i'm going yeah yeah
that's right yeah
tell them about the combustion chamber
that's right tell about air flow come on
talk about carburation go ahead tell
them you know i'm like that you know so
and another thing is is that you can see
videos
of canoe at the [ __ ] tr at the range
shooting
and he can shoot the dude is a [ __ ]
great
small arms expert now is it realistic
training now it's awful
what yeah it's room clearing very close
range room clearing
he's very fast he's good with pistols
and car beads
i mean he's a dude that you could take
to a [ __ ] fight enter
clearing out rooms you could you could
take him with you i'd be
more than confident he's good real good
so
when he does the john wick movie
he can do that kind of stuff i mean
maybe not
you wouldn't get away with that in real
life that's not the way gun would work
but he could hit targets like that
i don't know in real life they're
shooting back it's not [ __ ]
which is a totally different damn but
like it's a movie
it's a move and the fact that he goes to
those lengths to make it look as
realistic as possible
and you know just still be cinematic
yeah
i think the reason a lot of people like
keanu reeves is because he seems
you know i don't know the dude
personally i'm not saying but just from
everything that i've seen about him
interviews and stuff
he seems ego-free yeah he's very
down-to-earth
he seems yeah he doesn't seem like he
can do all that [ __ ] but he's not out
you know in contrast to i'm not meaning
to [ __ ] on tom cruise again
but in contrast to tom cruise who wants
everybody to know i'm a scientologist
and i'm gonna save the world
uh keanu is very seems very humble and
he's just kind of like
so i think that's why a lot of people
like him he just seems like an okay
tom cruise has expertise too he's just
he does he's
very up on himself that's what i mean
and i think that's what a lot of people
are responding negative to
negatively to nobody's responding to the
fact that you're good at [ __ ]
you know that's good but the fact that
you're telling everybody how awesome you
are
but the objectives keanu reeves is not
tom cruise
the opposite of canon reeves is steven
seagal
okay yeah okay that's the opportunity
i'll give you that you're right
just fake all right fake as [ __ ] all
right uh but kenner reeves is confident
in
in himself uh he does have a lot of
[ __ ] cool skills
and he doesn't have to pretend any and
he knows he's an actor
that's just that's just one of the
things he does he's got other [ __ ] that
he does
so his identity isn't totally invested
in acting
if you're all your identity is invested
in acting
there's not much to you sorry because
that's not that difficult you really the
thing about acting
as a career that's pretending yeah it's
like it seems to me i you know i would
never be good at it because i'm just
like too i'm not good at like pretending
to be
something i'm not um so i so i would
never be good at it
but i i admire people who are good at it
but if that's the only thing that you
have going on if you don't have
something
else to ground you whether it's you know
whatever it is like a relationship or
other hobbies or whatever
then you're going to like lose your
identity real quick
and i think that really kind of happens
with a lot of these actors and
especially ones that are really
successful because
if you get to a certain level of success
everyone's just going to like kiss your
ass and let you get away with [ __ ] that
a normal person would not
be allowed to get away with and um so
you're just going to keep pushing the
[ __ ] boundaries man
they're talking about tom cruise in
there yeah tom cruise is a pilot and
he's like
yeah yeah uh he rides bikes yeah my
issue with him is not that he can do all
those things that's awesome he's also
good with guns
he also just to me he comes across as
arrogant yeah he is
which i don't like that i think the
reason that a lot of people like keanu
is because he can also do all that [ __ ]
but he's not like a douche about it you
know what i mean
tom cruise is a kind of guy that um
if you met him and he liked you he still
wouldn't be able to drop the mask
he's gonna have to be to me he seems
he's gonna have to i don't even regard
it i don't even know if there's anything
behind it is what disturbs me about him
you don't do you know what i'm getting
at yeah i think there is it's just that
that's private he's not gonna let any
anybody know
you know if it's that buried does it
even really exist anymore
well i think he grew up in an
environment where he had to
[ __ ] constantly be putting on a a
public image
because in science in scientology here
scientology is about putting on a public
image well for others
constantly so you and also in
scientology you can't show any [ __ ]
weakness so they're just gonna like
[ __ ]
they're gonna jump right on that yeah
it's a pair of military religious
organization where everyone's trying to
be a damn army ranger
psychic jedi and ufo cultist
and also they're all beating the [ __ ]
out of each other in the
conference room like i said before on
the other show
tom cruise went and went to scientology
to get street cred
because he couldn't go to the service so
he needed some kind of training some
kind of background and credentials
in something and uh in self-improvement
you know what i mean and scientology
gave him that
and here's something though i'm gonna
i'm gonna say
and this is kind of i'm breaking from
the [ __ ] herd science
scientology's fake as [ __ ] uh it's just
big
obviously but tom cruise got the best
that scientology can offer
yeah most of the like peons
so he probably got
a pretty good experience well he got
validation
yeah i think that's what he wanted was
yes now does that training work some of
it might but
you he's not been he's not reversing
time and changing the whole track and
[ __ ] going up the bridge and [ __ ]
reaching ot levels and i'm i'm the only
person
that can save people in car accidents
and all this [ __ ] no but i think that's
a system that he can go into and he can
have rank in there and validation and
boss people around and
hang out with david miscavige and go out
all these secret bases and
look at the damn [ __ ] the [ __ ]
what is it the titanium tablets were
they titanium or were they [ __ ]
platinum
i think they were platinum yeah up to l
ron hubbard's [ __ ] secret writings
out in the desert
look man laugh all you want about
[ __ ] fake ass
i will that's the weird [ __ ] man
scientology's weird
and they had money secret bases and [ __ ]
and i don't believe in any of that
they're like but they're like the
world's
lamest supervision that's the weird [ __ ]
i can't imagine the amount of
hutzpah the amount of ego it would take
to be like my words are so profound and
precious
that we need to ensconce them on
platinum tablets and we need to like
put them in a bunker in the desert so
just in case
the world is destroyed by nuclear fire
you know from the ashes of the rubble
the people that survive
thousands of years from now we'll find
these words of wisdom we'll build a new
society
i can't imagine the amount of
[ __ ] audacity you would need
to actually have that thought in your
head i really do not
zach's in there bringing forth gay
images of fire
everybody's talking about tom cruise and
[ __ ] you know what he can do
and zach because tom cruise can twerk
but to put with david and miss cabbage
yeah see why did you all give me that
mental image i didn't know that
yeah those two there's two tiny little
men i invented that [ __ ] and zachary
internalized that [ __ ] it'll look just
like this at about this size
[Laughter]
i tease him tom cruise is probably
taller than me but not by much
david miscavige might be shorter than me
no he's little guy yeah
oh yeah i would like to punch david
miscavige
no he's not everything against the dude
i don't know well everything he does he
seems like a douche i find that
personally
he's doing that [ __ ] to the to these
willing members in that damn cult
that i don't know i said i find science
people are wonderfully fascinating and
listen
well those are the only people i feel
sorry for if you joined as an adult then
i can't help you
but people that were born in it yeah
i i feel sorry for them you know what i
mean yeah
jenny that's something you said you
thought of the other day well i know
well because he said something about it
and i'm like god damn it why the [ __ ] do
you put that image in my head i didn't
need that
why do i need image of like tom cruise
and like david mascaras doing that
i'm gonna have nightmares about that now
gross actually i think in terms of the
uh
old school at hollywood celebrities and
actress
the ones that would most likely make a
good
um translation to modern youtubing
would have been the 1970s and 80s uh
comedians
they they were good at it you know i
mean like the
people at the liars club like [ __ ]
what was his name
buddy hackett and [ __ ] all those
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] who were
damn drunk on the talk shows back in the
70s
they'd be drinking on the goddamn list
just like we oh my god paul lynde would
have made a [ __ ] awesome
if youtube had existed back in the 70s i
totally would have watched paulin's
youtube
paul lin would have [ __ ] commanded an
army of gays
zach if you don't zach got to know who
paul land is that [ __ ] was a
legendary
center square the center square of
hollywood square
and he was on a bunch of other he was on
a bunch of other [ __ ] shows and
i will also fondly remember him as being
the voice of templeton the rat in
charlotte
yeah it's just that this [ __ ]
character was sucking just larger than
life larger than life [ __ ] character
yeah i mean he was just hilarious he was
very happy and just
the innuendos you see that's what made
that's what made that generation of
comic or actually they were they weren't
he wasn't really a
comic he was a personality yeah
a television personality and what made
those guys so great
was just their ability to use [ __ ]
innuendo
because they had to get around all the
censorship and they could play word
games
and [ __ ] paint a picture and [ __ ]
that technically he didn't he didn't
[ __ ] say it
but you know exactly what that [ __ ]
said it was just hilarious man
see i'm so into people that use language
to just like that's why i love oscar
wilde i love like dorothy parker i love
all that kind of [ __ ] i love people that
can just like say something and then
you're just like oh whatever and then
like later you're like oh man that was
like the worst like sick burn ever
you know what i mean like you didn't
even think about it at the time i love
that kind of [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] excellent historious
pathetic yeah he he
he died kind of sad but he was
he was a [ __ ] great entertainer
and uh there was one little thing that
happened he brought some dude back
he was big in the [ __ ] gay club scene
he brought some uh
cutie boy back and they got high
went out on a damn [ __ ] ledge and
fell
remember that yep yeah he called the
cops he fell
some wild [ __ ] man it happens well yeah
but now
paul paul lind was uh he was cool very
cool everybody liked him
what did he die of alcoholism you know
what i can't even remember now
it's been a while
i don't remember i don't know because i
don't think he died at aids
no i think he killed himself didn't he i
don't know i don't i don't know you know
you could look it up somebody can look
that [ __ ] up for me i forgot how he died
kiernan said uh as much as [ __ ] as we're
talking like back in the 80s and 90s
when tom cruise was still hot most you
ladies would have hit him
yeah probably yeah yeah he would
even when i was like younger not really
i'm not
not really my type bro just not my type
you wouldn't have known back then though
because you didn't know who he was i
knew who he was in the 80s
he was in [ __ ] risky business i knew
that was before
that's before people knew about
scientology i kind of knew a little bit
about scientology because i really
i remember seeing like all the [ __ ]
commercials for dianetics and all that
kind of [ __ ] back in the [ __ ] 80s i
remember that [ __ ]
um but even if i had known about that
it's like even without that he always
i don't know i there was something about
him that always struck me as like really
unpleasant he always like came across as
like really like i said
really arrogant and i don't really like
that sort of super cocky i don't you
know i don't i don't know there's
something like really off-putting about
that so i always found him like really
off-putting
paul died of a heart attack okay there
might be a euphemism for [ __ ]
snorting coke
yeah they did that a lot back then
well yeah everyone was kind of usually
drugs
died of a heart attack it was actually
something like heroin
or [ __ ] snorting speed ball you know
or [ __ ] snorting and starting a bunch
of cool well like i said i really do
kind of feel like they tried to
they tried to keep them from getting in
trouble yeah they try to cover up a lot
of stuff especially if they're really
famous
um i don't know if they do that nowadays
because nowadays they better like find
out what the [ __ ] [ __ ] was
somebody to find the death certificate
but um
back then i i still kind of feel like
there was they had agents and [ __ ] like
that and they were just like yeah it was
it was a heart attack it was it's very
very sad but yeah probably
i think even a lot of a lot of
celebrities back then that died of aids
i think they didn't even want that
getting around because
i mean particularly in the 80s like
dying of aids was like a big
[ __ ] stigma about that so
you know [ __ ] even freddie mercury
didn't even say he had it until
like right before he died he wouldn't
admit it even though the rumors were
going around
you know what i mean so yeah that was
something happened a lot
um zach says gene harlow and joan
crawford are gay icons for whatever
reason
now imagine how big they'd be if they
were youtubers
um tila said tila said that they can
back uh what was it
tom cruise went on the arsenio hall show
it said golly oh golly
yeah that's like a fight tom
there's there was a time when tom
had to be [ __ ] just lily white as
snow
just looking you know without any kind
of sin he had to be
like fully stand up kind of guy see you
don't have any patience for that kind of
stuff i just don't
that was scientology talking i know i
don't have any patience for that
yeah quit being like that right just be
a normal person
no no that
tom truth can be a normal person that's
what i'm saying that's why i don't like
him
and i don't want to make him a superman
i always kind of got that vibe about him
like even back in the old days before
everybody knew about all the scientology
[ __ ]
it's like even in his film roles that
really kind of leaked through that sort
of
that just arrogance kind of like leaked
through and it just
i don't know it just pissed me off there
was something about it that really like
pissed me off lack of confidence maybe
what your your lack of confidence maybe
no i think it's their lack of confidence
no i know arrogance never pissed me off
i always thought it was just amusing
i don't know it's just about those music
well it's just something that threatened
it just get i'm not threatened by it it
just gets on my nerves i don't want to
be around
people like that because they just
they're tiresome to me that was so he
to me it's more tiresome then to me that
was just his stick
you know i mean i didn't really well i
don't like people with a stick i didn't
think that
you know what i mean yeah but that was
hollywood actors back then
i know that's why they were all like
that they were fake yeah that's what i
like a lot remember
i'm trying to take you back to those
times remember they were fake
tv was fake fake as [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
well yeah plastic
i wasn't really worried about it last
time because i wasn't really watching
but we all knew it was plastic
yeah i knew it was fake um it's just it
didn't matter
you don't realize it you go back and you
look at that [ __ ] today
and it just takes you back you realize
how fake and
plastic it was and how formulaic
everything was
every everything was just [ __ ]
pre-packaged homogenized and pasteurized
and
totally [ __ ] sanitized you know it
was just
fake ass [ __ ] yeah the two commercials
were coming and everything it just
crap we were lapping it up didn't know
any better
because that's the way that's the way
the product came to us
yeah you know and like i said the thing
about it too is that
i kind of feel like particularly people
that are really
into this whole good old days notion um
you know not so much nowadays but maybe
people that are really really
old now or you know the last generation
i kind of feel like they have this weird
good old days thing like oh the 50s and
before everything was like a pure
innocent time
um i hate to inform everybody but like
it's never been like that never
um the only difference is that you don't
hear about [ __ ]
because like i said all that [ __ ] about
like oh hollywood nowadays and like all
the [ __ ] scandals and [ __ ] like that
that was going on
way back in the early like in the early
20th century
murders drug addicts abortions
all that kind of [ __ ] was going on back
then they were just like much much more
careful about keeping a tight lid on
that [ __ ] because they knew that middle
america
wasn't uh having it so they really
really tried to keep it on the dl so
everybody would still buy movie tickets
you know what i'm saying um that that's
all it was the same [ __ ] was going on
back then is going on nowadays
they just were better at keeping it a
secret because they didn't have the
internet
that's all you know what i'm saying yeah
i guess
you guess yeah were you talking about
again
you missed that dory of my life yeah
yeah no
i was listening i was reading
i'm sure it wasn't important but um why
don't you go get me another drink
no how about that is it time to shut the
[ __ ] shut the show down no man i'm
gonna be doing this [ __ ] two hours and
43 minutes let me get one more drink
and then we'll yeah it's friday night
come on
uh you know but yeah so like i was
saying that whole [ __ ]
murder that i talked about before and
and you know there was that whole thing
with like uh
oh thank you zach only thing i do think
was better back then is people seem to
have better manners and get along more
and more
trustworthy maybe um
but i don't know i kind of feel like
maybe that's true but then maybe in a
way too that maybe
the fact that people had that perception
made it easier to
manipulate people and get around stuff i
think it was like easier to
prey on that because everyone was kind
of like
more naive maybe but
it's just really funny i used to talk to
my grandmother about this because
you know you know i grew up in the 70s
and 80s it was a you know it was very
glam rock it was new wave and everything
like that and that was kind of like
it was upsetting for older people that
there was all this kind of like
gender bending going on there was all
this kind of they didn't get it
and my grandmother use and she's a
lovely lovely
she was a lovely woman and um i used to
laugh because she used to stay
say stuff like um you know oh you know
we used to have all these what did she
call them
what what did she call gay men i can't
remember now but she had like a word for
them
i can't remember what it was and um she
was like well we used to have that big
that no one talked about
it no one talked about it so i kind of
think that
i i kind of prefer nowadays where
everyone's [ __ ] is just like
out and proud you know what i mean
because i feel like all this shit's been
going on for like thousands of years but
nobody talked about it like over certain
periods so when people remember
like the 50s for example as good old
days
same [ __ ] was going on the 50s is going
on nowadays it's just nobody talked
about it
that's all it wasn't like acceptable to
talk about
um that's all and you know like i said
when i was talking about the murder of
william desmond taylor earlier like i
said you had the whole fatty arbuckle
scandal
a lot of the movie stars back then in
the very early days of hollywood in
1910s 1920s even like
during the whole silent to sound era
same [ __ ] was going a lot of them were
drug addicts a lot of them were drunks
there was a lot of murders going on a
lot of [ __ ] uh underage
sex a lot of prostitution a lot of
abortions a lot of that kind of [ __ ] was
going on
but they abused their influence sure but
they were a lot better at keeping it
under wraps because like i said
yet one there was no internet absolutely
it was harder to find out about and two
they had a lot more invested
because back then the studio system you
basically had a contract with one studio
and they basically owned your ass
yeah um you could be in all their movies
but you had to present
a very particular like public face you
couldn't be seen
[ __ ] around your wife you couldn't be
right that's still going on now almost
that's what i'm saying but yeah
and another thing is is that the studios
own you
so they try to protect their investment
if you [ __ ] up they try to cover for
your ass
and they got so much money and so much
influence in the local government around
where those
studios were they could get the cops to
cover [ __ ] up for you
because well yeah
um because like i said it's all about
money you know you were invested in
these people people would pay a lot of
money to come see this person so
this person's image was very important
the directors and the studio [ __ ]
studio owners and people that were
[ __ ] studio executives
up top they were not only in with the
cops they were room with organized crime
too
they could do anything yeah big time
yeah
kieran says uh they're going to disagree
with me they think
that we over share a bit too much
nowadays
i don't know i don't know if i agree
with that me
um every just people in general oh um
i don't know i would prefer i mean yeah
it's like i don't necessarily want to
hear about some strangers like [ __ ]
anal fistula but
what's that it's it's a little like um
kind of a
growth she's sort of like well yeah i
don't get too much into it
you know that was just the first thing i
thought of i don't know so i don't want
to hear about like some strangers anal
fistula or whatever but
um in general i think it's a better
idea is laughing at anal facial [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what does that have to do with [ __ ]
i'm just snitches [ __ ]
because everybody's in general men get
anal fistulas too it's not just [ __ ]
but um talking about it oh okay
no i'm just saying that that was just a
general example but i'm just saying that
um in general i don't mind i kind of
like i don't know i i feel like
sharing stuff that's sort of personal
and embarrassing about yourself
or potentially potentially embarrassing
about yourself i think that
speaks more of people's honesty
than otherwise you know what i'm saying
so it's like
while you know for example if i was
at work like in a work situation and the
co-worker started telling me
like at length about their you know
whatever it was like
their [ __ ] fertility treatments or
whatever i wouldn't necessarily want to
hear that
but if i was just talking to like a
friend i totally don't mind
you know i totally don't mind talking
about that and honestly when i'm talking
to some of my friends like the more
personal like we talk about [ __ ] it's
like that's
it's totally cool with me i don't know
tila's in there talking about [ __ ]
sammy davis
sammy davis jr kim novak i don't know
who kim devek is
but i remember [ __ ] savvy i was a kid
[ __ ] growing up watching sammy and
sammy be
he was on all the [ __ ] talk shows and
he was always [ __ ]
mcn and [ __ ] and get guesting stuff and
showing up in movies you know cannonball
run and stuff
and i went back recently and saw some of
the stuff [ __ ] sammy davis [ __ ]
said and did on talk shows
that much they just don't make
[ __ ] like that anymore that
dude was a [ __ ]
class act yeah he really did a [ __ ]
class act
it was just another it was another time
and he was [ __ ] light years
ahead of [ __ ] general society at the
time the [ __ ] was just he was
brilliant
great entertainer and you know what's
funny about [ __ ] davis
forgotten kind of forgotten a lot
a lot of people don't remember him he's
not
they need there needed to be a movement
on youtube
to bring those classic [ __ ]
back
to the modern audience well we could
start it to show
these [ __ ] whipper snappers
the way true class was you know i mean
and the way
real celebrity was yeah he was a [ __ ]
hollywood celebrity but he was more than
that
he was a good dude too he seemed like a
good yeah
tilo was pointing out i put him up there
with elvis
and [ __ ] elvis is one of my favorites
and i put sammy up there with [ __ ]
elvis
and i put james brown up there with
[ __ ] those with those guys too
even though james brown had some [ __ ]
weirdness to his ass i [ __ ] still
like
still i still like james brown though
yeah but he was
he's a character he had some rough edges
on him but
yeah um well don't worry he was not dumb
he was very [ __ ] smart
very [ __ ] shrewd and cunning and he
knew how to run a business
and he ran his operation like a [ __ ]
mafia
he was about making money and when you
worked for james brown you [ __ ]
worked for james brown you didn't work
for anybody
else i mean but that was the era that
was the era that he was in and that's
how you had to do things
he ran a very tight ship for a dude that
seemed so fast and
loose he was a disciplinarian
yeah did you know that yeah he did not
tolerate
spit and polish he didn't tolerate any
[ __ ] he'd fire you in a heartbeat
well because the thing about people like
that too that especially people
that are really talented like that well
they expect the best from themselves
and they don't want everybody else
around them to like half-ass [ __ ] and
make them look bad either yeah
you wouldn't think brown would be a
perfectionist though he looked seems
like a wild man but no he was a [ __ ]
meticulous professionalist almost he was
almost like militant
in the way that he did [ __ ] they're very
ritualistic and [ __ ] you know
everybody's
[ __ ] outfits had to be [ __ ]
perfect you had to
he was into perfect like i said he
wasn't into half-assed no
don't have that [ __ ] i'm kind of like
that too i don't like it to be happy
and he lost well to an extent he [ __ ]
lost it at elvis's [ __ ] funeral in
graceland
there's a lot of reasons why you know
that [ __ ] happened that they're both
being southern and [ __ ]
and they were they were southern
republicans they had kind of this thing
going on they were anti-clan
southern republicans trying to bring
rock and gospel to the mainstream you
know in a time when
[ __ ] race was a was a big factor the
united states was very [ __ ] racially
divided at that time
and they were breaking breaking [ __ ]
boundaries
but so was sammy well and uh
i think tila pointed out earlier that
sammy davis jr kim novak
did he marry some swedish model or
something i can't remember he he was
into white chicks
yeah well like i said that was very very
not acceptable at that when he was kind
of well maybe not in the united states
mainstream but these are artists and
they didn't
[ __ ] apply they didn't really play by
those rules well in another way too i
kind of feel like look at um you know
performers like african american
performers that we had over here like
back in the 20s 30s 40s
like josephine baker people like that
who were a lot more
you know they'd go to europe and you
know they'd just be treated like oh
you're like a normal performer
over here it's like you could perform
but you got to come in the back door
like where the cooks are you can't come
to the front entrance because
yeah yes it was [ __ ] up for you know a
good
you know for a long time i went
i i gave my histories on all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] back of the day
segregation [ __ ] only went on for a
certain period of time
prior to before segregation there was
still all kinds of interracial mixing
people don't realize that
you know what i mean yeah there were a
lot of people in the [ __ ] american
history
that if you looked at the details they
were mixed but it wasn't mentioned yeah
it was just something that wasn't normal
like it happened but it wasn't something
particularly late
well and particularly like later on
right becoming
it kind of became a thing that like you
didn't talk about yeah
really all that segregation [ __ ]
happened after slavery not really before
or deering you know it was there was
[ __ ] going on in [ __ ]
all those island chains with the [ __ ]
pirates and [ __ ] there were women
women pirates and mixed women pirates on
the pirate ships
and this went all the way up into new
orleans because that was one of the
pirate towns
a more metropolitan or now not
metropolitan a more
universal culture the universe
was around going back to the 15 1600s
1700s
that's what was going on way way back in
those days
uh during the american revolution there
were a lot of
black people and mixed people in the uh
up in those 13 colonies that were free
that were fighting the british
there's all kinds of stuff that they
conveniently leave out
it's slightly whitewashed the history
well a little bit like i said because
just because history is
always a lot more complicated it's more
complicated than it is
okay well here's the thing the salem
witch trials another thing that they
leave out is that
most of the people in salem were at
least part indian they leave that out
and a lot of them were from haiti
well the one woman that started the
whole thing or
she didn't start the whole thing but
accusations against her yeah
um if you go to salem you'll find out
from the people that [ __ ] all
that the guides and everything they said
that pretty much
everybody in salem township during the
witch trial was
at least one quarter indian the only
people that were
a hundred percent white were like the
preacher because he was fresh from
england
everybody else had been there for
several generations breeding with
indians
because it and here's another thing most
indians
spoke more than one language and usually
their second language is french
or english and a lot of indians are
christian it had been christian going
back to the 16th 1500s sometimes
it's not what people think it is there
was a and another thing is that indians
had money
what they show in hollywood is not
accurate they had money they had guns
they had horses they had their own
nations they were at war with each other
indians had agency they were just
another one of the players
well like i said everything's always a
lot a lot more complicated
i mean when they make movies or when
they it's like you know it's it's easier
just to
distill it down to a simple narrative
because it's like a lot easier to
understand
if you made something that was like as
messy as real life right
it probably wouldn't make a good movie
it's kind of like one one of my favorite
westerns movie was called red sun
and it had um uh what's his name dude
from
from um uh dude from dead wish
uh charles bronson charles bronson and a
famous
japanese actor that plays in toro
toratora he plays a samurai it's about a
man i love torritory yeah we watched
that in school actually yeah
stories about american outlaw hooks up
with a samurai from japan to try to get
reclaim the emperor's sword that he was
going to give as a gift remember
to be president to the american
president and that movie was [ __ ]
great red
sun you guys could check it out anyway
no it's called red
what's it called red sun i don't know if
you had superman red son
i know yeah i think i said are you
thinking about the the yeah superman it
was called
red sun i'm gonna look it up but see the
superman was called red sun
and that's the way it is right whereas
this one was called red sun
just got red s-u-n sure right and um
in that they in one of the in one of the
this is happening in like the 1870s or
the 1880s
and in one of the scenes they come they
get into a fight with like some apaches
and they show the apaches and it's
nothing but like spears and loin cloths
and
like they're in the stone age and you
just gotta [ __ ] laugh
it's a little bit it's not a little
thing it was like two or three hundred
years
[ __ ] behind the times the apaches
[ __ ] look how tribal they are yeah
what the [ __ ]
they don't even know how to make real
well the apaches look like any other
person in america or in mexico they wore
[ __ ] pants
cloth shirts lever action rifles and
horses and [ __ ]
they had [ __ ] hats and [ __ ] money
and
you know the apaches were people they
they
[ __ ] followed like white women it's
cold out here
yeah they were just a gang of people
zach gave us thank you zach
you know of ira eldridge he was a black
man born in new york city moved to the
uk became a highly respected
shakespearean actor
and is buried in poland i don't but i
have to look that up now that's like a
fascinating story
so you know thank you for getting that
out
but uh but yeah it's well like i said
it's always kind of like
you know people gonna make movies you
make movies and you want it to have like
a narrative
thing because if you don't then people
are gonna [ __ ]
but history and like i said this kind of
ties back to what i was saying earlier
about how i'm fascinated by
history books that look into a history
of something that's seemingly
insignificant but is actually like
that you never really thought about the
history of before
but you know like food safety or like i
said like red dye
or whatever but then like you look into
the history of it and it just like
encompasses
all of these different um you know
fields of study and it's like super
fascinating
so i feel like that's kind of what
history education is kind of lacking and
i know why
because you know you can only cover so
much [ __ ] ground right i mean
the history of the world it's long it's
complicated you can only like hit the
highlights that's pretty much it
but i i feel like it
it would be better taught almost
concentrating on
these littler things that kind of like
shed light on larger trends you know do
you know what i'm saying
because i kind of feel like a lot of the
nuance is
lost because they have to cover so much
ground
in such a short time and so they skim
over a lot of stuff
and i feel like it's in the details that
you actually like learn [ __ ] about
history yeah like
because it makes it more relatable to
you yeah like little details like
late 1800s a [ __ ] large
percentage we were talking about like 60
percent of americans cavalry forces were
native american indians
because they all joined the cavalry
because they weren't allowed to hunt the
buffalo
and they were all american citizens so
they wanted to [ __ ] ride horses and
do something
and they came from a warrior culture
this is the cheyenne
you can find just google cheyenne
us army 1800s and you're going to see
that [ __ ]
they're just whole divisions of cheyenne
indians
wearing the american blue uniform with
stripes that should hold
military careers but they don't tell you
that
but because like i said i don't think
it's any kind of like nefarious plot or
anything no
i just think it's because there's so
much history that
you have to skim over a lot of it just
because you can't cover it all well some
people like to crystallize [ __ ] and make
it one way or the other that america was
totally [ __ ] racist and [ __ ] all the
time
everywhere at any moment and it wasn't
it was a mixture
depending on where you were and what
time what the situation was
who the because the united states
as a [ __ ] national government was
weak it was only in washington dc for
the most
part everywhere else was under the un
under the control of [ __ ] counties
and state governments you never could
tell who was in charge of some of these
counties
some of these counties only had a few
thousand people on
you know what i mean and then they were
rigged elections mormons were bringing
elections to get nothing but mormons
involved with their counties and there's
a whole books on that and [ __ ] that they
did
and then they would borrow money never
pay it back from other counties and it
was like part of the mormon wars
it's all kinds of [ __ ] interesting
[ __ ] in american history
europeans will say oh americans have no
culture oh no america's got a lot of
[ __ ] culture there's so much [ __ ]
that [ __ ] went down
past couple hundred years down here it's
not [ __ ] fun well and like i said
it's just that
it's sad that well history classes are
so limited yeah they can't tell you
everything
well in the sense they don't have a lot
of time and they have a lot of ground to
cover like i said and it's kind of like
you know when i was a kid you know the
whole [ __ ] uh
you know narrative was oh christopher
columbus came here and he discovered
america which he didn't really
but you know when this happened and that
happened and then they kind of like
oh and the pilgrims came and they kind
of like spread out over the west and it
was all awesome and whatever
and it's just kind of like so very basic
yeah that's kind of they just have to
kind of give you a basic outline but the
more you like look into [ __ ]
the more interesting it is and i think
that we're really missing out i think
that's why a lot of people find
history boring yeah because they cut all
the good [ __ ] out
well yeah well because they have to like
you know
like i said you only have a limited
amount of time and you can only cover so
much [ __ ]
so it's kind of like we just have to
give you a broad outline of [ __ ] and
it's like yeah i agree that's very
boring but
if you like look into some [ __ ] like way
deeper it's super super fascinating
and it's like i will go down a whole
like some days when i'm researching a
show or i'm researching a case or
something like that
i will go down a whole [ __ ] rabbit
hole all day long about some little
[ __ ] nuance of this case it's like oh
my god this law passed in this year what
is that all about and then like you go
down the [ __ ]
and it's just like i that's why i said
earlier why i love
books about histories of [ __ ] that you
didn't think was that interesting
all the interesting stuff is local stuff
everything's interesting all they did
and stuff was all the little local stuff
i was big into the us army and military
history
and there was so much local [ __ ] that
went down in america
the local like i mean it's a map they
had a [ __ ] battle
where an all black american infantry
regiment
got stationed outside of a damn little
bitty [ __ ] mining town
that was all white but the town only had
a few thousand people in it but the
[ __ ] black division had [ __ ] like
six thousand seven thousand dudes
well because the picking people at the
town were a bunch of [ __ ]
they wouldn't let the black troops come
into the damn saloon
all right so like they're stationed
right outside the damn town
all right and they can't go downrange to
have fun
well they disobeyed that order which i
wouldn't too like [ __ ] yeah
we're going to [ __ ] town i can't even
have a whiskey [ __ ] that yeah so they go
to town
and [ __ ] uh the saloon owner tries to
[ __ ] kick them out they're they're
trying to be paying customers all right
so they called out the damn police and
the police couldn't handle it so the
police put it kind of like a posse
together
and they got into a gun fight that
lasted like a whole day
all right like 12-hour gun fight for
just some dudes wanting to drink at the
tower
man right cheese and what was funny is
that the [ __ ] went on for about 12 hours
of course and hundreds of [ __ ] rounds
were [ __ ] fired off
and no one was hit well that's good so
they're
shooting at each other over this
disagreement about
going to the [ __ ] saloon all right
finally
only dudes could shoot at each other for
12 hours 12 hours a night about
something as insignificant as yeah
eventually uh the [ __ ] calmed down and
they decided nah
the american soldiers black or not can't
go to the [ __ ] saloon and they were
like yes
yes thank you it only took us 12 hours
to sort that out thank you they tried i
don't even want the [ __ ]
yeah they tried to arrest some dudes and
uh [ __ ]
they uh they dropped all charges but
that was a good one
i thought that was a good story see
that's a like i said that is
typical dude behavior just dude behavior
that's testosterone
well no i would do the same [ __ ]
thing well yeah
they were stationed out in the middle of
goddamn nowhere with nothing to damn do
and you couldn't go to the town that was
[ __ ] a couple hundred yards away and
go to the [ __ ]
right that's what i mean [ __ ] that you
couldn't spend your money there
what oh you don't want my mom yeah you
know what it's not good
because i'm not the same races yeah that
was somewhere out in the west though
that was i think that was somewhere out
near
california figures well
that that's totally it was hot and wild
west basically
so they didn't even want that's how
that's how committed to the racism they
were it's like we don't even want your
money
yeah well that was just that one town
dc and other guys got involved and said
no no
you got to let them come into town you
know and the cops were also
kind of like no they gotta you gotta let
these dudes come into town what are you
talking about
yeah they're out in the middle of
nowhere they're american soldiers
they got money you're not going to let
them come to the [ __ ] saloon
seems like you're shooting yourself from
the dick there i'm just saying a
business saloon owner
that's what i mean he owns a business
and he's like turning money away
yeah right i don't i don't know what
you're thinking nobody got hurt
well that's good at least they were all
like rotten shots or the guns no they
were doing an offer
and or the guns were shitty they weren't
trying to kill each other over it
they were shooting at each other man
give me a whiskey they were just
resistant i'm gonna shoot
near you yeah [ __ ]
why don't you talk to the people so i
can pee why don't you tell them that
you're gonna pee
because i just said that okay go ahead
were you being like yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're funny
why am i funny i don't know why i'm
playing just say you go to the restroom
or something you know you're going to
include them with you
i'm not saying i'm not saying i'm not
saying restaurant okay i'll go ahead
that sounds like something
that sounds so euphemistic okay they use
euphemism
i'm not using it you say you you say
restroom all the time i don't think i do
all right that's what i'm doing yeah
okay what do you guys want to talk about
everyone borrow money never give it back
honestly
see what tv's talking about
see she leaves me here to the camera she
says talk to the people
but i don't give a [ __ ] about talking to
the people i'll just sit here and be
quiet and put a drink
i'm not all that uptight about it i
would have ended the stream
i would have ended the stream an hour
ago and then what would you guys be
doing
sitting at the house drinking by
yourself probably
tina sent me a message to do that
tom talk about the best movie you've
ever seen as she's [ __ ] women
dennis is sitting back there on the back
[ __ ] show best movie i've ever seen
i'm gonna put them back up
you know i've said this many times my
favorite movie is actually predator one
so and i've talked about it ties blue in
the face
although
there i got a lot of best movies
terminator one alien one and two
the thing terminator one
i can escape from new york
what else is the best movie the best
movie ever
yeah i just i came in and you were
listing like
yeah let's list them off sci-fi like
yeah
the best movie ever um there's no way
that i can
choose that apocalypse now was really
good
shining's really good i'm gonna say the
shining is the movie that
any time like if tomorrow you said hey
wanna watch the shining
yep i can watch that over and over and
over again
film making is a dying art okay
it's a genre from another era
i really think it was at its height in
the 80s
although there was a lot of good in the
70s and the 90s also
it's gonna go the way of say like epic
poetry
where there's please call this great
poetry but you don't have people going
to poetry readings and you don't have
like
who's the best poet you know that shit's
played out
movies are going to be slowly replaced
by video games
i mean you know [ __ ] i love all the
fallout series
of movies i just i think it's great i'll
even sit and watch him
play fallout yeah even if he's just
decorating his
apocalypse apartment yeah um metal gear
i got metal gear five i [ __ ] love
metal gear
um they're just
interactive storytelling and action and
playing games is
is better you know what i mean [ __ ]
the laura croft series even going back
to the old [ __ ]
you know i like [ __ ] playing tomb
raider just solving puzzles and running
and jumping
it's hard for a movie to compete with
that kind of stuff
because a movie has to be it's a story
that has to be self-contained
and told within about two hours maybe
two and a half hours that's
that's about much as you're gonna get
out of a movie
and uh there's not a lot you can do in
that
um movies will be replaced by video
games and series
a series that's many hours hell yeah
you can do that well it's like reading a
really really good immersive novel
we saw spartacus blood and sand
we re-watched it recently and that's
still just
one of the best series of all times the
first episode isn't that great i mean
it's good but it's not great well it's
all set up it's a setup time but as soon
as they get to rome and get into the
gladiatory fights
that is just [ __ ] the great so is the
second season
we need to rewatch this we're going to
rewatch [ __ ] three and four too
because like i said there's like [ __ ]
four seasons which i didn't realize we
saw the first and the second one i think
right yeah
did we watch the third one no okay we
haven't seen the fourth one so we
haven't seen three or four
t if you want to see a badass series
some sexy ass white [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's some black people too in
there too man like a
duck dory oh yeah the the head of the um
head of the gladiatory school
of the gladiatorial yeah what was that
actor's name oh my almost something
another
[ __ ] man he was in 300 as well yeah he's
he was in that 300
he played one of [ __ ] uh the
messenger of [ __ ]
um of what's his name the uh
sorry not cyrus was it cyrus it doesn't
matter
nothing but sexy ass [ __ ] with
muscles fighting each other [ __ ]
saying sexy [ __ ] killing people and
[ __ ] cutting people's faces off
[ __ ] in with doing women and lucy
lawless is in it
there's all kinds of [ __ ] slaves and
sex slaves and slaves going on and it's
all happening
and then it [ __ ] ends in a slave
revolt and everything and
these [ __ ] ruthless romans and
[ __ ] the guy who owns the ludus who
was like a gladiator school his name is
batiatas
and i [ __ ] he's played by this
[ __ ] he's an irish actor
and he's just the best character the
[ __ ] he's the greatest character
in this [ __ ] movie he's a total piece
of [ __ ] he's a total psychopath
but he's the best character he's just
the most roman
of all these characters he's just
totally ruthless he says what he had to
say
everything is just about getting [ __ ]
get done
making money he's the worst rising to
the top on the backs of other people
trying to come up with this [ __ ]
badass grift
just and and he's using great oratory
power on people
and i just [ __ ] love the character of
batiatas and um
he's doing all this [ __ ] for the honor
of his family and this
well him and uh lucy lawless's character
lucretia
yeah they're kind of like whole you know
scam that they have going there
and the [ __ ] that they say to each other
also the [ __ ] between
lucy lawless's character and that [ __ ]
friend of hers
that's like the the wife of the um
what you call it the uh legatus
yeah super awesome i love all that catty
[ __ ] like the men are doing catty [ __ ]
too everybody's doing catty [ __ ]
but i love all that but even more like
all the gladiatorial fighting and stuff
that's cool too like i like all the gore
and stuff
but all of the [ __ ] where they're just
like
you know undermining one another like
with their [ __ ] it's just
all the little plots that they have like
against each other 300 dude's name was
xerxes that's right xerxes that's right
yeah
yeah xerxes messenger i haven't seen
that in a long time he's been played by
the same guy
he's an african um actor i think he's
from
nairobi yes where's that dude from
i don't know he's he's he's badass
looking i've seen him in a bunch of
stuff got a real [ __ ] nice physique
and he's got [ __ ] like a really cool
voice and
um just he he knocks it out of the park
in [ __ ]
in in spartacus uh just everybody's
great in it
but somebody asked but were there flat
tops in [ __ ] ancient rome
there could have been anything
we're willing to forgive there could
have been anything we can forgive
it was multi-racial multicultural
[ __ ]
capital [ __ ] area and they did have a
quite a bit of technology more than
you'd think they were just
possibly a few years away from an
industrial revolution but it never
happened
um for a lot of different reasons but it
could it could have had
they could have had an industrial
revolution at any minute they knew about
steam power
they knew about mass production they
just didn't really need it because
they had an excess of human labor and
they were insourcing everything to slave
labor
which really [ __ ] up technology
why build a labor-saving device when you
can buy a german slave
you don't need it it was cheaper you
know
just to buy a slave and you had all the
the goths were selling their own
children
for dog meat you know what do you need a
robot for what do you need a tool or a
machine for
so it's just well yeah when you have
like
other people doing things for you yeah
you don't really need to
invest in the technology machine or a
company a machine was worth a lot more
than a human
so you didn't need a machine you you
didn't need to
put a machine in a labor labor-saving
role the main thing machines were used
for they did have them
the main thing in rome machines were
used for was for
religious special effects like coin
operated dispense
right which seems a giant waste or
steam-powered
doors that would open up at the
appointed time
every time of the of the morning you
know they did [ __ ] like that
and um mechanical statues that moved
and did things they did that you know
animatronics
yeah talking about they had mechanical
computers to predict the location of
stars
in the future and in the past to tell
the horoscope of a person
uh we know this because they found the
anticathera device
so they were in an advanced society
and if you were to read the writings the
political commentary of the time it was
like it was written today
you're dealing with totally modern
people well like i said people haven't
changed
right exactly the same the difference
was that their society was organized
crime it was like a mafia
and they were just up front in your face
about it
yeah they totally were not trying to
hide that [ __ ] whatsoever
that was a virtue the realm
that the roman citizen was a man whose
value was predicated on his ability to
help his friends and his family and his
ability to
ruthlessly persecute and murder enemies
they considered themselves a masters of
creation and destruction just
just like count dante just like
dante creation and destruction well when
you said creation destruction i thought
you were going to talk about like
shiva or no no no count dante okay
so that that went into direction i
wasn't expecting yeah
kung fu master all right all right so
uh not this is pre-christian stuff
christianity
of course you know was kind of like a
the wussification of the western man
to where you started yeah yeah
you're starting to um try to bring in
these ideas of like well you know the
lion lane
laying down with the lamb and we have to
be like girls
and then we're all god's children
they're all sitting in it
romans didn't believe in that everything
was hierarchy who was above who
who could [ __ ] who it was sexual too
yeah who could [ __ ] who it was the [ __ ]
pyramid
all right they were like that oh my god
okay i'm ready for the pyramid right
yeah then tomorrow when i'm sober i'm
gonna be like what the [ __ ] yeah
um yeah [ __ ] pyramid they didn't really
have a legal system as you would know it
they had one but it was very basic
um and rich people didn't apply to that
you could buy yourself
out of that so just like nowadays yeah
and they show it in the series batiacos
went out and assassinated [ __ ]
assassinated writers he wasn't like
super slick about it either
no well that was no you were supposed to
he's like what i probably didn't do that
too you were kind of supposed to why
would i use it
yeah but yeah that was part of your
power
you know i killed that [ __ ]
because he deserved it
you know but then he's still like to all
the important people he was just like oh
goodness
isn't that tragic that that person got
murdered like that well lying
so sad lying lying and
lying and being duplicitous was also
part of your power
that was also part of roman guile well
yeah well and it was also kind of a
thing where in polite society you
weren't really allowed to call them out
on it to their face like in front of
important people i guess so it's kind of
like you had a lot of plausible
deniability and the fact that you were
like oh i'm so sorry that like your
whole entire family including your
children
got murdered in a really horrible way i
wonder who could have been behind
all of this treachery yeah
spoiler alert hernandez is in what's up
louie
louie i made some carnitas tonight man
they're [ __ ] great oh it really were
they were really good marinated that
[ __ ] in [ __ ] orange juice with a
little bit of cocoa powder
it was in the crock pot all night yeah i
woke up at four in the morning because i
had to go to the bathroom
and i smelled the pork yeah throughout
the whole house
yeah tea if you like sopranos you'd love
[ __ ]
uh do you know what i still haven't
watched all of the sopranos no i felt
like
you you would like you would like
spartacus i haven't watched sopranos all
the way through i haven't watched game
of thrones all the way through and i
haven't watched breaking battle with
spartacus is on i really need to get
through right
no it's on amazon prime it's on amazon
you can watch it if you have amazon
prime you can watch it for free but you
there's ads
yeah there's ads all right but that's
all yeah but no i i recommend that one
that's one you need to see
louie was asking best tv show ever
i have an answer for that you want to
hear it yeah go ahead twin peaks yeah
you would like you would say that
twin peaks um one of these days i'm
still gonna do like a big mega
make a review on all three seasons when
i sit down and watch all of that because
like i said i've seen the first two now
when you say tv you're also talking
about netflix and all that or
or just television or cable what exactly
is he talking about
well anything that wasn't like
theatrically released i guess is fair
so anything that's like a series because
like i said a lot of people would say
game of thrones or
uh breaking bad or you know something
like that daredevil season two
a lot of people are saying ozark which
i've been wanting to watch that [ __ ]
because
jason bateman's in that yet and it's
like i love him
so one of these days i'll get around to
watching that i promise
yeah i would say daredevil season two
would be my favorite i had the punisher
in it
i liked all the daredevil seasons yeah
but season two was the best one
now i have to watch them all again yeah
i remember the first one being the best
but
i don't know maybe that's well i don't
know like i said i'm i like a lot yeah
somebody brought up dexter dexter was
good too
and a lot of it you know what a lot of
people bitched about like how it ended
and true detective was also good i
wasn't yeah i wasn't
super super happy about the way that
dexter ended
but they had to end it somehow they had
one
yeah i was i wasn't as pissed off about
it as a lot of people were
t if you like that wasn't great but it
wasn't if you liked [ __ ] dexter you'd
love dude love florida
that [ __ ] series was florida as [ __ ]
that was miami as a [ __ ]
thing with [ __ ] what was that one um
what was it called uh the one that had
[ __ ] mark wahlberg in
the movie true uh oh right right the one
that uh
yeah it's a good the true crab story we
just reviewed that yeah she was good
i can't remember where right now i'm too
director remember
it was good i'll remember it like 15
minutes from now
yeah yeah true detective like i said we
haven't uh
he always remembers i love that movie i
got to do that one again
it was so good yeah
it's rare that you can get a good story
in a two hours
well that one [ __ ] and it's rare too
that both of us can watch a movie
together and we're gonna
have like a [ __ ] blast with it
because normally like
he likes stuff i like stuff like
sometimes we like the same [ __ ] but
a lot of times [ __ ] i like he doesn't
like i was laughing my ass off that
movie was like
such a good time it was like so
entertaining even though it was like a
[ __ ] up story
but um i saw him saying true blood
either like even though a lot of people
have recommended that to me
i just the thing about it is like i
watch a lot of
movies and i read a lot of books i don't
get into a lot of series because i
always kind of feel like
oh man i really need to watch that
series but i don't want to start doing
it because i feel like it'll be too much
of a time commitment
yeah so i kind of feel like i don't
start it
and so i've gotten like really really
behind like i said i am one of the
very few people in the world probably
that has never seen a single episode of
game of thrones even though i have seen
all the spoilers so i know what's gonna
happen in all of them
but i haven't like watched any of them
and um
i think i've only seen maybe one episode
of breaking bad and i feel really bad
about that because i really need to
catch up on the [ __ ] because everybody's
seen that [ __ ] from me
t says i've never seen dexter said i
know i can't believe it
i can't do it too i
i love dexter i really do and i think
that they're doing
um stranger things y'all you know what
i love stranger things sophie says her
favorite was twide no and she's talking
about the old twilight zone wait the
original
yeah yeah that's good well soap's gonna
be here next month people she's gonna
hopefully she'll be on the show last
time she had a panic attack
she's coming mid april right yeah i
think it's 80 minutes next month yeah
yeah yeah
no mid or beginning i don't remember i
think i thought it might have been in
the 11th
it's my channel well that's mid april
yeah um
okay i'm gonna give you some [ __ ]
homework man
watch [ __ ] the superman red sun
watch dexter and watch
spartacus blood and sand
you want to watch at least the first two
seasons to sparta because i can't vouch
for three and four because we haven't
seen it
we'll watch with the first two the first
two seasons how much [ __ ] i gotta get
spartacus were great great and and
here's the thing that was around 2000 i
don't know 2006 or 2008 i think it was
2008
when spartacus first came out and and
they were doing [ __ ] in
that series that you can't do anymore
that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
i think it's just to pc i don't think
they'd [ __ ] be able to do all that
weird
sexual [ __ ] [ __ ] that they were doing
and all that weird stuff i don't know
about that i think they could
yeah i see well that's the thing it's
like people say that but i've seen way
weirder [ __ ] like
in movies nowadays than like that it was
pretty cool it was good and
you know i've read a lot of roman stuff
and [ __ ]
listened to a lot of professors talk
about asian rome it's pretty accurate
now is all the facts fashion accurate
no not really uh it's a little better
like there's one place
for a couple episodes they go into a
basically a [ __ ] underground fighting
pit
where there are no rules there aren't
any rules at all because there are rules
it's like it's like thunder dome and
some of the style that's going on in
there
it's kind of [ __ ] gothic you know
what i mean i don't think the romans
would have [ __ ] really had that
extent well
like i said it's kind of well you have
to it's fictional
um there comes a time when it's like
kind of like well
we're going into a space where this is
like
cinematic and you want stuff that looks
good
but that is still cool enough look at
that people aren't gonna question it
like it's not gonna bring them out of
the story you know what i mean
i mean there's always gonna be those
people that are like well actually they
didn't wear that stuff and blah blah but
those people are like
no fun and you don't want to hang out
with them so you know louie's saying hbo
rome was good yeah i want to check that
out too yeah a lot of people are
recommended that we really need to get
around it there's so many [ __ ]
i have like like i said you guys i have
this massive list of movies i have this
massive
series this is why i started doing my
own [ __ ] movie review [ __ ]
like i said i'm four episodes into it
because i have this massive list of
movies that i know he doesn't really
care about seeing
and i wanted to watch them and i was
like well why don't i
just review then i'll put up a couple
like [ __ ] episodes a week
so i started doing that but it just
seems like really overwhelming because
there's so much stuff that
i'm behind on like new movies and old
ones because there's a bunch of old ones
that i
you know haven't seen or want to
re-watch and it's just like taking
forever it seems to me like it's taking
forever
yeah you know what i mean it's like i
just watched this week
i did uh a lot of people recommended
shirley to me with uh elizabeth moss
about shirley jackson
and i just watched that and i reviewed
it so i'll be up in like [ __ ] for
probably like four weeks from now
but um i loved it by the way uh it's
awesome
but it's not a horror movie but i don't
know it's
horror adjacent i guess you could go on
um and i did a gl movie as well
you know but didn't that funny we
haven't lost the [ __ ] stream
i think it maybe it was those lights
maybe that's what was causing it
which sucks because it's like i like
having the party lights on it's all
festive and [ __ ]
but maybe it's like too much information
we'll see
i mean we've been going for three and a
half hours
and we haven't lost and we didn't forgot
to turn it on wednesday and we also
didn't lose that stream
wednesday and that was like two hours
two and a half hours something like that
yeah so i guess we've learned something
today
yeah we've learned something don't turn
the [ __ ] party lights on
because it [ __ ] up your [ __ ] might be i
think it might be
i don't know if that's it entirely
because like i said sometimes
we've done shorter streams like during
the week where we didn't turn that [ __ ]
on and it's still shut off
but i don't know maybe that's something
else but it seems like it's a
it's friday night and it hasn't shut off
the whole time yeah
how long have been streaming three hours
and thirty two it's probably about time
you think i think it's about time yeah
see everybody's like recommending new
stuff and it's like i want to watch it
all
yeah i just don't have time and sophie
was saying it's like she always feels
like she's wasting time like when she's
watching movies and stuff
and it's like i get it i feel the same
way like i said i started this new
um review show and i'm trying to get
ahead
so i've been trying to like watch a
bunch of movies this weekend like review
like record reviews of them so i can
have some in the can
and so me just sitting there
like paying attention to a movie like in
my office
is like really i always feel like i
should be doing something else at the
same time and
i it's sad to say i usually do i usually
have
i have a movie going on on the laptop
over here and then i'm like doing some
work over here i'm just keep glancing
over at it
it's like i probably get the gist of
what's going on you know what i mean
sad i just feel like i i have that thing
where
i feel like if i'm only concentrating on
one thing that i'm like wasting
time which is probably like sad i feel
like that's a younger person thing but i
have that as well
so you know if you have that too don't
feel bad because i also have that
um all of netflix's narcos series are
great see it's like there's so much
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] i gotta watch and a
lot of people have said american horror
story
seriously i've only seen the first
season which i really liked but i
haven't watched any more of the seasons
and what are they at like
[ __ ] season six seven i don't even
know how many seasons there are
and i really need to get to that too
so much stuff that i have to watch i
just don't have time and i have like a
bunch of books i got to read too
i got a [ __ ] pile i want to watch
season three of
[ __ ] the punisher season two was we
season
one and two was pretty weak oh no no
season one was week of season two that's
up there now
yeah i watched the first couple episodes
it was it seemed better
i gotta see season season one of the
punisher wasn't too good
it was kind of weak i didn't find it but
you i see what you're saying but uh some
people said too they're they're doing a
um reboot or continuation of the dexter
series
yeah uh with same dude and everything
like that so i'm actually like i've
kind of heard some buzz about that so
i'm very excited about that
because they knew that a lot of people
like i said i didn't get i wasn't that
pissed off at the ending i understand
we saw it probably like a year or two
after it came out so the
you know indignant people had like
already
moved on to something else to be mad
about but um
when i saw the ending i was kind of like
eh but i wasn't
really i wasn't that upset about it it
didn't bother me that much
but i know a lot of people were bothered
about it like not as much as maybe they
were bothered about the whole [ __ ]
lost
ending which i also didn't get but
you know i saw people were mad but i
didn't i wasn't mad about it it was fine
it wasn't great it was fine but they are
um they're doing a new season so i'm
excited about because i love michael c
hall he's awesome
and uh he's been in some other [ __ ]
didn't we see like a [ __ ]
movie was it on netflix it was like a
thriller or something like that
and he was in it he was like a dad of a
daughter and she got like
kidnapped a murderer or something he was
playing like a brit what do you talk
about
we saw i can't i think we reviewed it on
our matinee show
it was on netflix or something and he
was uh his
daughter got kidnapped i want to say
remember the dev zone
michael anthony hall remember that
serious
well yeah we have it yeah we did we
review it or no just the movie
never reviewed the series i didn't even
realize
until much later that they had made a
series out of that
with that only thought it only had a
couple of good episodes that really
stood out
no it was good yeah i gotta get back
into it maybe
and it was kind of like one of those
series where
like old school series where you could
kind of like watch
they were they were standalone they were
a little bit standalone yeah
in the sense that you could kind of come
in at any time and it wasn't like oh i
miss like all this stuff i gotta go back
and catch back up
because i kind of feel like nowadays in
this
uh you know era of everyone binge
watching everything
back in the old days they kind of had to
make everything every single episode of
a show had to be
sort of standalone so that people could
come in at any time
and you could just kind of have an entry
and you weren't like totally lost
yeah they don't really do that much
anymore but i understand that because
everyone's viewing habits have changed i
get it
but uh all right you seem like you're
fading out yeah i'm fading out
i don't know we're almost at four hours
which is good yeah
i run out of things to say you have
things to say
and i've gotten to the bottom of my
third large drink
uh we gotta go find pookie i don't even
know what time it is
i'm gonna go find her and bring her back
inside
and then so i guess we will see
everybody
when sunday afternoon we'll talk about
some movies
like we usually do on sunday tomorrow
we'll probably
sleep in and then go out do whatever it
is we do on saturdays
so as always thanks for dropping by he's
already leaving well i gotta go find
boogie
[Laughter]
10 hours he can't even be bothered
all right so that's nice all right so
we're gonna call it a night so thanks
everybody for dropping by
remember like share subscribe on all
your social media
if you like the show and you would like
to financially support it would be much
appreciated
go to our patreon page patreon.com 13
o'clock podcast or
go to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast.wordpress.com and there's a
button in the sidebar which goes to a
paypal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation like i said anything
that you give would be much appreciated
and we will see you guys on sunday
afternoon where we will talk about a
movie
thank you everybody for dropping by as
always
good night